Hey everybody. Hi there. We hope everyone is doing fabulous this week. And you guys know for us it's spring break. Our kiddos are out of school and we're taking the week off to, you know, unplug and spend time with our families. So this week, we wanted to take a look back at one of our favorite episodes we have ever done on Office Ladies. It is our interview with the fabulous Steve Carrell. I am telling you guys, this was such an absolute delight.
大家好。大家好。我们希望大家这周都过得非常棒。你们也知道，对我们来说这周是春假。我们的孩子们放假了，所以我们这周要休息，你知道的，远离电子产品，花时间陪伴家人。所以这周，我们想回顾一下我们在《办公室女孩》做过的最喜欢的节目之一。这是我们对了不起的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的采访。我跟你们说，这绝对是一种极致的享受。
I love Steve. We love him. He's just the best. It was so fun to catch up with him. And he has a new show out on HBO. It's called Rooster. You guys, it's hilarious. Get this.
我爱史蒂夫。我们都爱他。他真是太棒了。能跟他叙旧真的太有趣了。他在HBO有一部新节目要上映。剧名叫《雄鸡》。伙计们，这剧太爆笑了。你们听着。
It's HBO's most watch comedy debut in over a decade. Well, that's a pretty big deal. And you can see more than just Steve Corel in this show. You can also see Nancy Correll. She has a cameo in it. So definitely check it out. We think you'll love it. Yeah.
这是HBO十多年来收看人数最多的喜剧首播集。好吧，这可真是件大事。在这部剧里你不仅能看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。你还能看到南希·卡瑞尔。她在里面客串了。所以一定要去看看。我们觉得你们会喜欢的。对啊。
Steve said in an interview, she stills the scene. And you guys, we hope you just have the best week ever. Please enjoy our interview with Steve Correll. and we'll be back next week with all new episodes of Office Ladies. That's right. We've got some really fun episodes coming up. We've gotten all about, we have a movie rewatch that is pretty special. And we have some new interviews. It's going to be a great time. Plus, we have a special bonus Mother's Day episode. And you guys, we want to hear from you. We have set up a folder on the Office Ladies website called Tribute to Our Moms. Go over there. Write us about your moms.
史蒂夫在采访中说，她抢了整场戏的风头。伙计们，我们希望你们能度过最棒的一周。请欣赏我们对史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的采访。下周我们将带着《办公室女孩》的全新剧集回归。没错。我们有一些非常有趣的剧集要播出。我们已经准备好了所有内容，我们有一期非常特别的电影重温。我们还有一些新的采访。这将是一段美好的时光。此外，我们还有一个特别的母亲节彩蛋节目。伙计们，我们想听到你们的声音。我们在《办公室女孩》官网上建立了一个名为“致敬我们的妈妈”的文件夹。去那儿看看吧。写下你们的妈妈的故事给我们。
We can't wait to share about it. All right. See you. soon. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Happy Wednesday, everybody. A very happy Wednesday. This is one of the most exciting Wednesdays for me. This might be one of my happiest Wednesdays. Office ladies, listeners, we have a special guest today.
我们迫不及待地想分享了。好的。回见。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的办公室爱好者的播客节目。每周我们将深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是办公室女孩6.0。大家星期三快乐。星期三快乐。对我来说，这是最令人兴奋的星期三之一。这可能是我最开心的星期三之一。办公室女孩的听众们，我们今天有一位特别的嘉宾。
The one, the only, Steve Corral! We have been waiting for this ever since the beginning of the podcast. We are so excited to have him on, and you guys are going to love it. We are dedicating this entire episode to Steve. He's going to talk about all of his time on the office playing Michael Scott. We could not be more excited for you to hear it. Also, I hope you guys, when you listen, the thing that just warmed my heart, was for me, it was just three friends getting to hang out who had missed each other and hadn't seen
唯一的那位，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔！从播客一开始我们就一直在期待这一天。能请他来我们超级激动，你们也一定会爱死这个采访的。我们将这整期节目献给史蒂夫。他将谈论他在《办公室》饰演迈克尔·斯科特的全部时光。听到这些，我们内心激动得无以复加。同时，我希望你们在收听时，最温暖我心的那一点——对我们来说，就是三个想念彼此、好久不见的老朋友聚在一起。
each other in so long. So I just hope as you listen, you get to feel that with us. It was like no time had passed. We just were so happy to see our old friend. I really feel like we captured what it's like to sit on set with Steve Carell. People always ask us, what's it like to work with Steve Carell? This interview captures what it's like. Yeah. These are the conversations. This is how we would laugh. Yeah, these were our Monday morning chats after the weekend. Absolutely. Before we get to the interview, we do want to give a big shout out to our Facebook fan page. I hopped on there and I wrote a message. I had to literally figure out Facebook in order to do it. You did. You were like, I don't know my password. I don't know anything. I had an old account that was like five years old
所以，我只希望当你们收听时，能和我们产生共鸣。就好像时间从未流逝。再次见到老朋友，我们感到无比高兴。我真的觉得我们捕捉到了和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起坐在片场的感觉。人们总是问我们，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起工作是什么感觉？这次采访就捕捉到了那种感觉。是的。这些就是对话。这就是我们大笑的方式。是的，这就是我们周末过后的周一早晨聊天。绝对是的。在进入采访之前，我们要向我们的Facebook粉丝专页大声致谢。我上去写了一条消息。为了做到这一点，我简直不得不重新研究怎么用Facebook。你确实是。你当时说：“我不知道我的密码。我什么都不知道。”我有一个五年前的旧账号。
or something. But I went on there and I asked you guys, what do you want us to ask Steve Correll? And oh my gosh, Did you show up for us? It was amazing. So awesome. You guys sent in thousands of fantastic questions. I also want to give a big shout out to Nikki, who moderates the Facebook fan page because she helped us go through and pick out some of your most asked questions. And we asked Steve your questions.
诸如此类的。但我上去了，我问了你们一个问题：你们想让我们问史蒂夫·卡瑞尔什么？天哪，你们太给力了！太惊艳了。太棒了。你们发来成千上万个精彩绝伦的问题。我还要向管理Facebook粉丝专页的妮基表示热烈感谢，因为她帮我们筛选并挑选了你们问得最多的几个问题。我们把你们的问题拿去问了史蒂夫。
And some of the questions are so good. I would have never thought of them. I know. And they made us laugh. And you'll hear it. You'll hear it. All right, let's take a break. And when we come back, our interview with Steve Corral.
有些问题真的太棒了。我自己绝对想不出来。我懂的。而且它们逗笑了我们。你们待会儿就会听到了。你都会听到的。好了，我们先休息一下。广告回来后，就是我们对史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的采访。
This episode is sponsored by BetterHelp. I've been thinking a lot lately about how important it is to take care of our mental health. Not just when things feel overwhelming, but as part of everyday life, therapy really isn't just for crisis moments. It's a tool. Yeah. I've seen how powerful it can be. But I also know that finding time for therapy can be really tricky. And that's why we love BetterHelp.
本期节目由BetterHelp赞助。我最近一直在思考照顾好我们的心理健康有多么重要。不仅仅是在事情让人感到难以承受的时候，而是作为日常生活的一部分。心理咨询真的不仅仅是危机时刻的工具。它是一种工具。是的。我见证过它能有多大力量。但我也知道，要抽出时间去做心理咨询真的很棘手。这就是为什么我们热爱BetterHelp。
Everything is online so you can schedule sessions by phone, video, or even message chat. They have the largest and most diverse network of therapists over 30,000, covering everything from anxiety and depression to stress and relationship issues. And here's the thing. If the therapist you find isn't the perfect fit for you, you can switch anytime, easily and at no extra costs. So take a moment and prioritize your well-being. being with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies to get 10% off your first month.
一切都在线上，所以你可以通过电话、视频甚至文字聊天来安排咨询。他们拥有最大、最多样化的治疗师网络，超过3万名，涵盖从焦虑、抑郁到压力和人际关系问题的方方面面。关键是，如果你找到的治疗师并不完全适合你，你可以随时更换，轻而易举且无需额外费用。所以，花点时间，通过BetterHelp将你的幸福放在首位。访问BetterHelp.com斜杠office ladies，即可在你的第一个月享受九折优惠。
That's BetterHelp. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Jenna, I am so excited because guess who's sitting next to me, Steve? It is a nice girl on office ladies. We're all here in our glasses. Remember, we didn't have these when we worked on the show together. Did we all three wear glasses? The very last season, I really needed them for table reads. Right, for reading. Yes. But look at us now. Now we're here. I know. I know. I know. In need of eyewear. Should I just kick it off with our very first question we always ask? We have a favorite first question. We have all of our guests. Okay. Here it is. It is. It's really hard. It's really hard. Ready? How did you get your job on the office? I auditioned. I have to say the audition for the office was unlike any audition I've ever had. And I'm sure you had the same. experience because it felt like it was a workshop. It didn't feel like an audition. There didn't seem to be a ton of pressure. You just went in and they had a camera, but you didn't think there was anyone
网址是BetterHelp点com斜杠office ladies。珍娜，我太兴奋了，因为猜猜谁坐在我旁边，史蒂夫？这是一个在办公室女孩节目里的好女孩。我们都戴着眼镜坐在这里。记住，我们一起拍这部剧的时候可没有这些。我们三个都戴眼镜了吗？最后一季时，围读剧本的时候我真的很需要它们。没错，为了阅读。是的。但看看我们现在。现在我们在这里。我知道。我知道。我知道。需要眼镜。我是不是应该直接从我们总是问的第一个问题开始？我们有一个最喜欢的第一个问题。我们所有的嘉宾都有。好的。就是这个。真的很不容易。真的很不容易。准备好了吗？你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我试镜了。我得说，《办公室》的试镜和我经历过的任何试镜都不一样。我敢肯定你也有同样的经历。
outside of the, you know, the one or two people that were in the room. So it was very low-keyed and very supportive. I remember we did a screen test together. Because after I auditioned something like seven times. I made it to the end, I guess, and I was like I was one of the final four, and they paired me up with you for a couple of scenes. That was crazy. I'd never done something like that before. I said, anybody but her. You're like, I don't care. No chemistry. What is her name, Gemma? Jimma Fisker. I don't like it. Don't think it's going to work. I don't think Jima Fisker's going to be on the show. No, I remember auditioning with you, and I remember how grounded you were instantly in your character.
因为感觉它就像一个工作坊。感觉不像是试镜。好像没有那么大的压力。你只是走进去，里面有一台摄像机，但你不会觉得除了你知道的房间里的那一两个人之外，还有什么人在。所以气氛非常轻松，也非常支持。我记得我们一起做过试镜测试。因为在我试镜了大概七次之后。我想我坚持到了最后，我成了最后四个人之一，他们把我跟你配对演了几场戏。太疯狂了。我以前从没做过那种事。我说：除了她，谁都行。你当时说：我不在乎。毫无化学反应。她叫什么名字，杰玛？杰玛·菲斯克。我不喜欢。觉得行不通。我觉得杰玛·菲斯克不会出演这部剧。不，我记得跟你一起试镜，而且我记得你瞬间就融入了你的角色，基础打得那么扎实。
And I thought, you know when you read with someone, you don't know who they are as a person. Yeah. And you immediately think, well, that's who she is, clearly, because you can't separate it at that point. But then you find out, like, everyone has completely different personalities than the characters are portrayed. And it's kind of amazing.
我想，你知道的，当你和某人对台词时，你并不了解他们作为一个人是什么样的。是的。你马上就会想，好吧，她显然就是那样的人，因为那时候你无法把角色和演员分开。但后来你发现，每个人的真实性格都和他们扮演的角色截然不同。这真是太神奇了。
Like, once, I remember, can I tell a story? Like, right off the bat. Yes. Oh, my gosh. I remember when we were at our first studio, our first soundstage out in Culver City. And we were shooting the pilot. And I was at craft service. And I had taken a can of Diet Coke or something out of the six-pack.
比如有一次，我记得，我能讲个故事吗？一上来就这样。好的。天哪。我记得当我们还在卡尔弗城的第一个工作室、第一个摄影棚时。我们在拍试镜样片。我在餐饮服务区。我从六连装里拿了一罐健怡可乐什么的。
And, you know, there was that plastic, the carrying six-pack thing. And I started breaking it down. I started cutting the edges before I threw it in the trash. Yes. You know, because of the dolphins. And you don't want to. And I remember you walking up and commending me for, doing that and that stuck with me like oh yeah i was just kind of doing it as a courtesy to the dolphins
然后，你知道的，那种塑料的六连装提手。我开始把它剪碎。我在把它扔进垃圾桶之前把边缘剪掉。是的。你知道的，为了海豚。你不会想……。我记得你走过来称赞我这样做，这给我留下了深刻的印象，哦，是的，我当时只是出于对海豚的礼貌顺手做的。
yes and and but i remember you kind of giving me a bat on the back and saying hey good for you nice job that is such a specific memory to remember i did like it's one of my strongest memories from the first episode and i thought she's so nice that's so it's so nice to be with nice people I guess that was the takeaway. Like, oh, this is going to be great. Fellow dolphin lover, you know? I do that at home. I probably said I do that at home.
是的，而且我记得你拍拍我的背说，嘿，真不错，干得好。这是一个多么具体的记忆啊。我确实很喜欢，这是我从第一集里得到的印象最深的记忆之一。我想，她人真好，能和好人在一起真好。我想这就是我当时最大的感悟。就像，哦，这会很棒的。同道中人的海豚爱好者，对吧？我在家里也这样做。我大概说过我在家里也这样做。
Yeah. Yeah, I love to see it. And we should shout out to all the people out there. Cut the plastic. Don't, you know. Yeah. Keep plastic down. Yes.
对，对，我很高兴看到这个。我们应该向外面的所有人大喊。把塑料剪断。别，你知道的。减少塑料。是的。
For one thing. That's right. This is going to be a PSA. It is so funny, though, like where your brain goes, because my strongest memory of the pilot is how you had to go down those stone steps outside to get, like, to crafting everything. You know, like you had to go outside the building down these stone staircase. And Oscar and I were leaving at the same time.
这是一方面。没错。这将是一则公益广告。不过太搞笑了，你的大脑会飘到哪里去，因为我对试镜样片最深刻的记忆是，你得走外面那些石阶下去，去拿零食什么的。你知道的，你得走出大楼，顺着这些石台阶下去。奥斯卡和我当时正一起离开。
And we had done sketch comedy together for years, right? So we just went back to our silly schick. And he goes, let's walk down the stairs together the same way. And I said, okay, Oscar. And we started to go down the stairs with our arms flinging about. And we turned and the whole like producing team was walking behind us. Like Terry Weinberg, Howard Klein, all of those people. And I was like, Oscar, there's a bunch of people behind us.
我们一起表演过很多年小品喜剧，对吧？所以我们又回到了我们那些傻里傻气的把戏上。他说，我们用同样的姿势一起走下楼梯吧。我说，好的，奥斯卡。然后我们开始挥舞着胳膊走下楼梯。我们转过身，发现整个制作团队都在我们身后走着。比如特里·温伯格、霍华德·克莱恩，所有那些人。我当时就想，奥斯卡，我们后面有一群人。
He goes, then we have to keep doing it. Yeah, you have to own it at that point. So I'm like, okay, that's the one thing I remember. But then you find out later on those intimidating people weren't intimidating at all. No. Everyone who was completely in. Like so nice and rooting for us. Yeah.
他说，那我们得继续演下去。是的，到了那个地步你就得硬着头皮演到底。所以我就想，好吧，这就是我记得的一件事。但后来你发现，那些原本让人感到令人生畏的人其实一点也不吓人。是的。每个人都完全融入其中。人都超好，而且都在为我们加油。是的。
Everyone's in the same boat. I have a question that came from our office ladies fan group. This is from Carly D. Carly would like to know, what was your process and inspiration behind playing Michael? How did you craft this character? I remember meeting with Greg Daniels up at a deli, like on the top of Mulholland.
每个人都在同一条船上。我有一个问题来自我们的办公室女孩粉丝群。这是卡莉·D提出来的。卡莉想知道，你饰演迈克尔的心路历程和灵感是什么？你是如何塑造这个角色的？我记得在穆荷兰山顶上一家熟食店见到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
And we didn't know each other at all. And it's before I got the part, actually. He, you know, he was, I think he was meeting with some of the people who were sort of in the mix, the final mix for Michael. And we just discussed the character and talked about what his foibles are and what is his dreams and hopes.
我们当时完全不认识对方。而且那其实是在我得到这个角色之前。他，你知道的，我想他当时正在见一些进入迈克尔候选名单的人，也就是最后入围的人。我们只是讨论了这个角色，谈论了他的缺点是什么，他的梦想和希望是什么。
And I had a pretty specific take at that point. And it wasn't Ricky Jervases, you know, and I've told this story a million times that I chose not to watch the British version because I just didn't want that to influence whatever this version was going. to be. And because he was so, he was clearly so great at it. It was such a distinctive character. I didn't want to do an impression of him. I remember you telling me that. And I remember telling
我当时有一个相当具体的看法。而且不是瑞奇·热维斯的版本，我讲过一百万遍这个故事了，我选择不看英国版，因为我只是不想让它影响这个版本最终会成为什么样子。而且因为他演得实在太好了。那是一个非常独特的角色。我不想模仿他。我记得你跟我说过这个。我还记得我告诉你，
you that I had chosen to watch the entire British series and completely copy Lucy Davis. And was basically doing a Lucy Davis impression to get the job. So I really, so not true. Yeah. But also kind of true. I don't think so. Until, you know, especially for the pilot because we were doing it word for word. And I was like, I think she nailed it. Like, I don't know how to say the line better than that. So I guess I'm just going to go with what she did. Well.
我选择看完整部英国系列剧，并且完全复制露西·戴维斯。基本上就是在模仿露西·戴维斯来争取这份工作。所以我真的，完全不是真的。但也算是真的。我不觉得。直到，你知道的，特别是试镜样片，因为我们是逐字逐句地演。当时我就想，我觉得她演得太棒了。我不知道怎么能把台词说得比她更好。所以我想我还是照搬她的演法吧。好吧。
But I remember you saying you'd never seen it. And I didn't really impress. I didn't really impress. I didn't because, you know, I watched like a minute of just to get a sense of the tone of the show, sort of how dark and very dry, very dour, kind of bleak, which I loved. I loved how still it was at times. But his character was so specific, I thought, no, I can't because that's what I'll want to do. I won't see it any other way.
但我记得你说过你从来没看过。而且我其实也没怎么模仿。我真的没有模仿，因为，你知道的，我只看了一分钟左右，为了感受一下节目的基调，那种黑暗、非常干瘪、非常沉闷、有点凄凉的感觉，我很喜欢。我喜欢它有时那种静止感。但他的角色太独特了，我想，不，我不能看，因为那会成为我想走的路。我不会用其他任何方式来看待这个角色了。
And I think Greg agreed with that as sort of a template for doing it. And we were definitely on the same page in terms of who this guy could be and could become. And early on, I started thinking about an arc too, like where, where, because you hope, you know, you don't go in thinking this is just going to be a pilot or this is just going to be six episodes. The hope is, the character starts here and ends up
而且我想格雷格也同意将其作为表演的模板。在塑造这个家伙是谁、将来会变成什么样这一点上，我们俩的意见绝对高度一致。早期的时候，我也开始构思一条故事线，比如，因为你心存希望，你知道的，你不会觉得这只是一部试镜样片或者只有六集。希望是，这个角色从这里开始，最后以某种方式结束。
way somewhere else. There's no way of really knowing where a character's going to end in the last episode. But I kind of, in my mind, I had a plan. Like, because these characters, the hope was that all of these characters
在最后一集之前，你真的无从得知一个角色最终会走向何方。但在我脑海里，我有一个计划。因为这些角色，我们的期望是所有这些角色都会改变、演变和成长。
would change and evolve and grow. and that's part of what's fun about watching a show is to see progress in these characters. So that was sort of the plan going in. That was sort of the hope. It was one of those parts that you just pray that you get because, well, you know, at that point, certainly we were all just happy to be working.
这也是观看一部剧的乐趣所在，那就是看到这些角色的进步。所以这就是当时进入剧组的计划。这也是某种希望。这是一个让你祈祷自己能得到的角色，因为，好吧，你知道的，在那时，当然我们所有人都只是高兴能有工作。
Yeah, yeah. But on top of it, it just seemed like, what a perfect thing to be a part of. Yeah. And everyone who I met who had been involved with it seemed great and smart and nice and kind. And all of those things just made it so appealing to want to be. I was, you know, crossing my fingers.
是的，是的。但除此之外，它看起来就像是，能成为其中的一部分是多么完美的一件事啊。是的。我遇到的所有参与过这部剧的人看起来都非常棒、聪明、友善和仁慈。所有这些因素都让它变得如此具有吸引力，让人想要加入。我当时，你知道的，在心里默默祈祷。
Oh, I know. I remember thinking like, I can do this. Like this one I can do. Yeah. But that was Pam and I didn't get it. But then I got to be the accountant. And then I was like, no, I can really do this. Have you ever worked in an office in real life?
噢，我懂的。我记得当时想的是：我能演这个。这个我可以演。是的。但那是帕姆，我没得到那个角色。但后来我成了会计。然后我就想，不，我真的能演这个。你现实生活中在办公室工作过吗？
Or ever had a boss like Michael Scott? No. No. No. I never have. Not an office worker. I did a lot of, you know, I did a lot of waiting tables. I sold wine over the phone at one point.
或者遇到过像迈克尔·斯科特这样的老板吗？没有。没有。从来没有。我不是办公室职员。我做过很多，你知道的，我做过很多服务员的工作。我还曾在电话里卖过葡萄酒。
How do you sell wine over the phone? Exactly. I mean, you can't taste it. How does it? It's a beautiful bottle. Well, you describe it. But we didn't get to drink the wine, but you have to describe a wine based on a, you know, a paragraph that they've written on each, on each wine and varietal characteristics of each wine. It's a hard sell.
你怎么能在电话里卖酒？没错。我的意思是，你又尝不到。怎么卖？这是一瓶好酒。好吧，你描述它。但我们喝不到酒，你必须根据每个酒和每种葡萄品种的特点，在每款酒旁边写的一段话来描述它。这很难推销。
I mean, hello, do you like wine? I mean, click. Okay. Was the office your first lead role? Yeah. Yeah. I think it was. I had done, it was a, it was really fun to do.
我的意思是，喂，你喜欢酒吗？然后，挂断。好吧，办公室是你的第一个主演角色吗？对的。对的。我想是的。我演过，那部戏真的很有趣。
But I played a crazy Greek chef on a sitcom with Annie Potts and Tim Curry. So that's, that's the, that's the sitcom that I had done. And I did a, I did a show just before the office starring Tom Papa, a really funny comedian. And he had a show. Come to Papa. And he was, he was so great. the show, you know, only lasted a few episodes. So I went from that and then auditioned for the office when that, when that ended.
但我曾在一部由安妮·波茨和蒂姆·克里主演的情景喜剧中扮演过一个疯狂的希腊厨师。所以，那就是我演过的情景喜剧。在《办公室》之前我还演过一个节目，主演是汤姆·帕帕，一个非常搞笑的喜剧演员。他有一个节目叫《来找帕帕》。他真的很棒。不过这个节目，你知道的，只播了几集。所以我从那个节目出来，等它结束后，就去参加了《办公室》的试镜。
But no, I'd never done a lead. I'd never done a lead role. Because I have such a memory of you, Steve, sitting over in that little sofa at front reception or the chair, sometimes that was in front of Michael's office, just studying your lines because you would have to carry every scene. And I just breezed through and said something snarky to Kevin and then breezed out, you know, for the most part. But I always thought was there a lot of pressure to be the lead and have to carry all of that?
但没有，我从来没有担任过主角。我从来没演过主角。因为我对你有一个深刻的记忆，史蒂夫，你坐在前台接待处前面的那个小沙发上，或者有时坐在迈克尔办公室外面的椅子上，一直在背你的台词，因为你必须撑起每一场戏。而我总是轻松走过，对凯文说句刻薄的话，然后轻松走开，你知道的，基本上是这样。但我一直在想，作为主演并且必须挑起这一切，压力会不会很大？
Not not with that group of people because I felt like everyone was an equal component of that show. I didn't feel that way. I didn't feel like I was carrying any more load than anyone else. Because when you think about it, you know, yeah, I had a lot of dialogue, but everyone was there all the time. And even if you were in the background of, of a scene. You're still acting. You're still active.
不会，和这群人在一起不会，因为我觉得每个人都是这部剧平等的组成部分。我没有那种感觉。我不觉得自己承担了比其他人更多的负担。因为你想想，好吧，我的台词确实很多，但每个人都一直在场。而且即使你只是场景中的背景人物。
You, like all of us had character stuff going on at all time. So I don't think enough can be said for the fact that to be, to just be present on that set, everyone was working really hard. But it didn't, it didn't, I don't make it sound like it was hard work because it wasn't.
你仍然在表演。你仍然很活跃。你，就像我们所有人一样，一直都有角色的事情在发生。所以我觉得怎么强调都不过分，那就是为了在这个片场保持存在感，每个人都在非常努力地工作。但这并没有，我不想把它说得好像工作很辛苦，因为一点也不辛苦。
It was really fun. Right. Because everyone was there supporting each other. So no, I never felt, I never felt like any undue pressure. And also the writing was so good that at a certain point, it became very easy to memorize lines because you started to understand exactly how the writers were writing it and how they were also writing to us, like to our characters and to all of our voices.
真的很有趣。没错。因为每个人都在那里互相支持。所以不，我从没觉得，我从来没觉得有什么不合情理的压力。而且剧本写得太好了，以至于到了一定程度，记住台词变得非常容易，因为你开始准确地理解编剧是怎么写的，他们是如何针对我们、针对我们的角色以及针对我们所有人的声音来创作的。
Yeah. So I find that if dialogue's really good, it's generally pretty easy to remember because it makes sense. That's right. I always think about that too. If it's well written, I have no problem. And then our joke is we'd never make it on a medical show. Because all of the things they have to just quickly rapid fire off. I'd be like, oh, no, I'm not going to audition for that. I'll be a disaster. Yeah. No, that would be tough. So, Steve, we have talked about many times on this podcast just about our gratitude for your just stability and consistency and your leadership,
是的。所以我觉得如果对白真的很好，通常是相当容易记住的，因为它讲得通。没错。我也总是这么想。如果剧本写得好，我就完全没问题。然后我们的笑话是，我们永远进不了医疗剧。因为他们必须快速连珠炮似地说完所有那些专业术语。我会想，哦，不，我才不去试镜那个。我会是一场灾难。是的。不，那会很难。所以，史蒂夫，我们在本播客中多次谈到，我们对你的稳定性、一致性以及你的领导力充满感激，
so much so that a fan wrote in Sarah H and said, we've heard how supportive and professional Steve is on set, and I would love to hear Steve's perspective or advice on setting the tone at work and fostering a supportive environment. Let's start by saying, I am pretty great. So some of it's just in your DNA. I mean, you had a shirt you would wear. That said, I'm fantastic, right?
以至于一位名叫莎拉·H的粉丝写信说：“我们听说史蒂夫在片场是多么地支持他人且专业，我很想听听史蒂夫关于在工作中确立基调和营造支持性环境的看法或建议。”首先我要说，我相当棒。所以有些东西是刻在你的基因里的。我的意思是，你以前穿过一件衬衫。上面写着“我很棒”，对吧？
That's right. So that sets a tone. Right. Just reiterate that it's me. That's really nice of you to say. But I, again, I felt like I was part of this very unique ensemble. And so I never thought of myself that way. I thought of Greg as our leader and our sort of,
没错。所以这就定下了基调。没错。只是重申那是我。你这么说真是太好了。但我再次觉得，我是这个非常独特的演员阵容的一部分。所以我从不那样看自己。我认为格雷格是我们的领导者，也是我们在这个世界的某种，
mentor in terms of this world and he oversaw everything and everyone was so nice. Everyone was so kind to each other that I never got a sense that it should be any other way than just in terms of the production of the show. Like from from wardrobe to the writers to the all of the crew, you know, catering, craft service, everybody felt like they were a part of something. The other part of it is, I believe sincerely that every one of us knew, no matter who watched it or whether it had any sort of longevity in terms of viewership, even if, you know, if we got canceled after a season or two or three, I was so, I think we were all so happy and thankful for the time that we got to work on the show and to be with one another. It was a special thing. And we were aware of how special it was in the moment.
导师，他监督着一切，每个人都太好了。每个人对彼此都那么友善，以至于我从未觉得除了节目的制作本身之外，还应该有任何其他的方式。比如从服装到编剧，再到所有的剧组人员，你知道的，餐饮、餐饮服务，每个人都觉得他们是其中的一部分。另一部分是，我真诚地相信我们每个人都知道，无论谁看它，也无论它在收视率方面是否有长久的生命力，即使，你知道的，如果我们播了一两季或三季就被砍了，我太，我想我们所有人都为能有机会在这部剧里工作、能彼此相伴感到如此高兴和感激。这是一件特别的事情。而且我们在当时就意识到它是多么特别。
For sure. For sure. I always was just super thankful for the writing because it was like, you know, when you do an improv show or a sketch comedy show or something and there's one person that wants the joke, wants the joke, wants the joke. And they just kill the show. I never felt that on our show. It was like, if Phyllis had the best button, she could level the room or Oscar or Creed. It didn't matter. Like the jokes came from everyone.
肯定的。肯定的。我总是超级感激剧本，因为这就好像，你知道的，当你做一个即兴表演秀或素描喜剧秀之类的节目时，总有一个人想要那个梗，想要那个笑话，想要那个笑梗。结果他们直接把节目搞砸了。在我们的节目里我从没有这种感觉。就像，如果菲利斯拿到了最好的包袱，她就能镇全场，或者是奥斯卡或克里。这都无所谓。笑话来自每一个人。
It was a real creative collective. And the writers wrote that way and Greg treated us that way. Like Greg could look at a scene and be like, no, you know what? It's not working with Jim getting the laugh. Let's flip that and let's have Stanley say it. Right. And then it just floored everyone. And so I always felt that way.
这是一个真正的创意集体。编剧们就是这样写的，格雷格也是这样对待我们的。比如格雷格看了一个场景会说：“不，你知道吗？让吉姆来抖包袱效果不好。我们换一下，让斯坦利来说。”没错。然后全场都被惊艳到了。所以我一直都有这种感觉。
And I feel like Greg set that tone for us that like everybody gets. to play. You're exactly right. Everyone got their shot. Not just that, but everyone else loved it. Everyone else was supportive of it. There was no resentment, no ego involved. And like, why not? That's the way to do it. And I think you can see it when you watch the show because there is a calm to it. Like, no one's everyone, it's all good. Everyone's everyone is, everyone's loving each. other, you know, in terms of us as actors and people beyond the characters. I get so excited for conference room scenes because those were our rapid fire things. I mean, Michael is up there, but literally every single person in the room has either a bit or a look,
而且我觉得格雷格为我们定下了这样的基调：每个人都可以参与。你说得太对了。每个人都有机会表演。不仅如此，其他人也都非常喜欢。其他所有人都对此表示支持。没有怨恨，没有个人 ego（自我）在里面。而且，为什么不呢？这才是正确的做法。我想当你观看这部剧时你能看出来，因为有一种平静感在里面。就像，没有人的情绪……每个人，一切都很好。每个人都在，每个人都深爱着彼此，你知道的，就我们作为演员以及角色之外的人而言。我一看到会议室的场景就会超级兴奋，因为那是我们连珠炮似地抛梗的时候。我的意思是，迈克尔坐在前面，但字面意义上房间里的每一个人要么有一个小包袱，要么有一个眼神，
and it's just so fun to watch. Almost impossible to get through. Oh, and we didn't. Oh, my God, we laughed so much. Well, people are very excited for you to talk about some of your favorite memories of shooting the office. Specifically, they're curious if you have a favorite episode, which I think is like asking, do you have a favorite child?
而且看着太有趣了。几乎没办法顺利演完。哦，我们确实没演完。天哪，我们笑得太厉害了。人们对你能谈谈拍摄《办公室》的一些最喜欢的记忆感到非常兴奋。具体来说，他们好奇你有没有最喜欢的剧集，我觉得这就像在问，你有没有最喜欢的孩子？
It's very hard. It's so hard. Yeah. That is hard. You know, my last one, talk about hard, it was a really difficult episode to do. But I also loved it at the same time because it was sort of that end game for Michael. It was that the culmination, showing the growth that he didn't need the big sense. of. He didn't need the big party. He could say goodbye to all of his friends on his own terms without
这太难了。太难了。是的。这太难了。你知道的，我的最后一集，说到难，那一集拍起来真的很不容易。但与此同时我也很喜欢它，因为那是迈克尔的结局。那是高潮，展现了他的成长——他不需要盛大的场面。他不需要盛大的派对。他可以按照自己的方式与所有的朋友告别，而不需要任何，
any of the, you know, the fanfare. Exactly. And so that, that, I really enjoyed, you know, having that character evolve to that point in that moment. And people always point to this one. But, um, but dinner party was dinner party is up there. And, you know, we'd come back after the writer strike. So that was the first thing that we had shot. I know you've discussed it, but I think everyone was so ready to get back to work and had really missed each other. And this is an episode that had just been sitting there waiting to happen for a while. And it's so weird and kind of dense thematically and crazy and had great guest appearances and great sight gags. What was also really dark in a lot of ways and very sad.
你知道的，那些大张旗鼓的场面。没错。所以，我很享受，你知道的，让这个角色在那个时刻演变到那个地步。而且人们总是会提到这一集。不过，但是，“晚宴派对”也在其中。而且，你知道的，我们在编剧罢工后回来了。所以那是我们拍摄的第一件事。我知道你们讨论过，但我认为每个人都准备好回去工作了，而且真的很想念彼此。这是一集酝酿了很久、终于得以拍摄的节目。它真的很诡异，主题上可以说是相当深刻，而且很疯狂，还有很棒的客串演出和出色的视觉笑梗。不过在很多方面也很黑暗，非常伤感。
Yeah. And kind of emotionally fraught. So there was a lot going on in that one. So I like that one too. We didn't realize until we were breaking it down and we did a little Googling. Apparently, it was a huge bomb when it first aired. It was not a fan favorite. It is not what it is today.
是的。而且在情感上有点紧绷。所以那一集里有很多内容。我也很喜欢那一集。直到我们剖析它并进行了一点谷歌搜索，我们才意识到。显然，它在刚播出时是个巨大的票房毒药。它并不是粉丝的最爱。它不是今天这个样子的。
But it was people did not care for it. The show in general was a huge bomb when people first saw it. This is true. I, you know, acquired taste, I suppose. Another one to your point that people did not like it first was Scott's Tots. Yes. And I loved doing that episode because it was so horrible. But I think expressed so much about this guy's persona because his heart definitely in the right place and a huge heart, but so wrong.
但当时人们并不怎么喜欢它。这部剧总体来说在人们刚看到它时也是一个巨大的票房毒药。这是真的。我，你知道的，这需要慢慢培养品味，我想。另一集符合你说的、人们一开始不喜欢的剧集是《斯科特的 Tots》。是的。我很喜欢拍那一集，因为它太可怕了。但我认为它很好地表达了这个家伙的人格，因为他的心绝对是善良的，而且有一颗巨大的心，但错得很离谱。
No follow through. And I think there was a talking head something to the. effect of all the stupid things I've done in my life, this was the most generous or something like that. It was something to that effect. I think it's like of all the empty promises I've made in my life, this one was the most generous. That's great memory to that. That's it. That's such a hard line to say with a straight face.
没有后续。我想有一个纪录片访谈大概意思是：“在我做过的所有蠢事中，这是最慷慨的一次”或者诸如此类的话。大概就是这个意思。我想它的原话是：“在我一生中做过的所有空头支票里，这张是最慷慨的。”记忆力真好啊。就是这样。用一本正经的表情说出这么难的台词。
You have so many amazing talking heads. We talk about it every week. and I sort of go and look at the deleted scenes and there's some real gems in there too but Jenna your favorite is... I have a favorite. Yeah. And we have an audio clip of it
你有那么多精彩的纪录片访谈。我们每周都在谈论这个，我有时会去看删减片段，里面也有一些真正的宝藏，但是珍娜，你最喜欢的是……我有一个最喜欢的。是的。而且我们有它的音频片段，
so that we can listen to it together. Okay. Is after Michael Burns his foot on the Foreman Grill. Oh yeah. And you very angrily explain how it happened. You're so annoyed. You're so defensive. Like, why do I have to explain this?
这样我们就可以一起听了。好的。是在迈克尔在乔治 Foreman 烤盘上烫伤他的脚之后。哦，是的。你非常愤怒地解释它是怎么发生的。你太烦躁了。你太防备了。就像，为什么我得解释这个？
But I guess here it goes. Again. Wait, we got to hear it. I enjoy having breakfast in bed. I like waking up to the smell of bacon. Sue me. And since I don't have a butler, I have to do it myself. So most nights before I go to bed,
但我想事情就是这样的。等等，我们得听听。我喜欢在床上吃早餐。我喜欢醒来时闻到培根的香味。告我吧。既然我没有管家，我只能自己动手。所以大多数夜晚在我睡觉之前，
I will lay six strips of bacon out on my George Foreman grill. Then I go to sleep. When I wake up, I plug in the grill. I go back to sleep again. Then I wake up to the smell of crackling bacon. It is delicious. It's good for me. It's a perfect way to start the day.
我会在我的乔治 Foreman 烤盘上摆好六条培根。然后我去睡觉。当我醒来时，我插上烤盘电源。我又回去睡觉。然后我醒来时闻到滋滋作响的培根香味。这太美味了。这对我有好处。这是开启一天完美的方式。
today I got up, I stepped onto the grill and it clamped down on my foot. That's it. I don't see what's so hard to believe about that. I love the big sigh. After you've explained how you eat bacon, six trips of bacon every morning, you're like, so today. I think my favorite part of that was when he says. And it's good for me. Just slipping in.
今天我起床了，我踩到了烤盘上，它夹住了我的脚。就是这样。我不明白这有什么难以置信的。我太喜欢那个大大的叹气了。在你解释完你是怎么吃培根的——每天早晨六条培根——之后，你说：“所以今天。”我想我最喜欢的部分是当他说。这对我有好处。就这样轻描淡写地带过。
How good. How healthy eating six trips of bacon in the morning. Oh. But there's so much about that if you unpack it. Like, it actually is really nice to wake up to the smell of bacon. I have that memory from childhood. It's comfort. You wake up on a Sunday, dad's downstairs, making the pancakes, making some bacon.
多好啊。早晨吃六条培根有多健康。哦。但如果你把它拆解开来，里面有很多东西。比如，醒来时闻到培根的香味确实很美好。我有来自童年的记忆。那是种安慰。你星期天醒来，爸爸在楼下，做着煎饼，做着培根。
It is actually a really, he has a point. Maybe just made bacon. He doesn't say it the way you just did, though. That's the problem. And what was so great about those talking heads and so terrifying in a way, it was they were so well written that you just didn't want to screw it up. You didn't, you, there was an obligation, and I know you guys felt this too. Like when you had a really good line and here it comes, you would try to do everything you could to take the pedal off a little bit.
其实他有他的道理。也许只是刚做好了培根。不过他说话的语气可不是你刚才那样。这就是问题所在。那些纪录片访谈最棒的地方在于——在某种程度上也挺吓人的——它们的剧本写得太好了，以至于你根本不想把它搞砸。你不会，你有种义务，我知道你们也有这种感觉。比如当你有一句非常棒的台词，而它就要出场了，你会尽一切努力稍微收一点油门。
You know, don't, don't floor it for the joke. Really ease off and let it seem like this is just a natural extension of what this guy is thinking or what these women are thinking. And that was the hardest part is to not point to all of these fantastic jokes to just make them feel conversational and also just to not laugh. I'm sure I laughed 20 times during that trying to do that talking head. There's one talking head. I, what was it, that I could barely get through? And it was the same sort of thing. It was something so ridiculous.
你知道的，别为了搞笑而猛踩油门。真的要放松下来，让它看起来就像是这个家伙脑海里自然延伸的想法，或者这些女性脑海里的想法。最难的部分就是不要刻意去指着所有这些精彩的笑话，而是让它们感觉像是日常对话，而且还要忍住不笑。我敢肯定我在拍那段纪录片访谈时笑了20次。有一个纪录片访谈。我，是什么来着，我几乎都演不下去了？而且也是类似的情况。太荒谬了。
There's one in the bloopers. You know, Isabel's obsessed with the bloopers. She loves them. So she'll be like, oh, mom, you're at season seven. There's great bloopers. I'm like, okay, is. But there was one, Steve, that you could not get through where you said, I'm going to get it wrong, but you're like, Michael's like, I'm not a bad guy.
花絮里有一个。你知道的，伊莎贝尔迷恋花絮。她太喜欢了。所以她会说：“哦，妈妈，你到第七季了。那里有很棒的花絮。”我说：“好的，伊莎贝尔。”但有一个片段，史蒂夫，你根本演不下去，你当时说，我可能会说错，但你是这么说的，迈克尔说：“我不是个坏人。有时候我用我的车撞人。”就是那个。那就是我想的。是的。你根本演不下去。有时候我用我的车撞人。是的，当我开车撞了梅雷迪思的时候。就像试图为自己做过的事开脱一样。
Sometimes I hit people with my car. That's the one. That's what I was thinking. Yeah. You couldn't get through it. Sometimes I hit people with my car. Yeah, when I hit Meredith with my car. Like trying to absolve myself of having done it.
我不是个坏人，有时候。我只是用我的车撞人。我记得当时在演。我快要演到了。是的。但我就是演不下去。这太，这是，知道自己每天都要去上班，
I'm not a bad guy sometimes. I just hit people with my car. And I remember doing it. And I'd be getting close. Yes. And I couldn't get through it. It was so, it was, it's fun going to know you're going to go into work every day. and laugh until you cry.
然后笑到流泪，这种感觉太有趣了。是的。我在那个片场的每一天，每天至少有一个时刻，我笑到眼泪夺眶而出。我的意思是，这是多么大的恩赐啊。是的。是的。谁能有这样一份工作？所以迈克尔·斯科特这些年来扮演过很多角色。
Yeah. Every day I was on that set, at least one point of the day, I was laughing until tears were coming out of my eyes. And I mean, what a gift. Yes. Yeah. Who has a job like that? So Michael Scott had a lot of characters that he would play over the years.
史蒂夫，我们找到了一段删减片段，我想跟你分享一下。我不知道你还记不记得。你知道的，等你听到它就会想起来了。这是第三季《罪犯》那一集的。迈克尔解释了他所有的角色、特别是监狱迈克这个角色的创意或者说灵感来源。我真的很想让你听听。山姆，你能放一下吗？当我还是个小孩子的时候，我们在学校里开过一次全校大会，一只巨大的猫头鹰飞出来，发表了一场非常激昂的演讲，大谈要发出呼声、不要污染环境。
And we found a deleted scene, Steve, that I wanted to share with you. I don't know if you'll remember it. You know, when you hear it, you'll remember it. But it's from season three in The Convict. Michael explains where he got the idea or I guess inspiration for all of his characters, in particular prison, Mike. I really wanted you to hear it. Sam, can you play it? When I was just a little kid, we had an assembly at school where a giant owl came out and gave a very impassioned speech about giving hoots and not polluting.
你知道吗？我再也没有污染过环境。就在那个时候，我意识到用角色的身份说话的力量。当你穿着精心制作的服装，或者用不属于你自己的声音说话时，人们才会听你说话。
And you know what? I never polluted again. It was right then that I realized the power of saying things as a character. People listen to you when you were wearing an elaborate costume or speaking in a voice that is not yours.
你能相信这段被删掉了吗？这就解释了监狱
Can you believe that was deleted? That explains prison. and Mike. Date Mike. Everybody. Michael Scarn. Anyone, anytime you let a conference room meeting in a costume with a voice. You thought this is it.
迈克。约会迈克。每个人。迈克尔·斯卡恩。任何时候，任何人穿着服装、用着某种声音领导会议。你当时想的就是这个。
They're going to hear me. This is how I am most effective. Because you don't give any hoots anymore. You're, well, are you give a hoot? You don't pollute. Clearly, this relates back to me tearing apart the plastic, you know. Yes. Even still.
他们会听我的。这才是最高效的方式。因为你不再发出任何呼声了。你，好吧，你是发出呼声了吗？你不污染环境。显然，这又回到了我撕碎塑料的那件事上，你知道的。是的。直到现在。
You don't pollute. Steve Correll gave a hoot. Yeah. You sure did. I, boy, I mean, that's sort of like that vague, foggy, as I was hearing it, I kind of recalled. Yeah. But there are thousands of those. There are like different versions of all of this stuff and things that could have made, you know, could make a difference either way.
你不污染环境。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔发出过呼声。是的。你确实有。天哪，我的意思是，这就有点像那种模糊的、雾蒙蒙的记忆，当我听到它的时候，我有点想起来了。是的。但那样的片段有几千个。有所有这些东西的不同版本，以及那些无论如何都可能会产生影响的事情。
Yeah. But they were so good. You know, the editors and Greg, I never regretted anything that was taking. taken out of the show. I, like, had complete confidence that, because you know how some people get possessive, like, well, why did that scene go? Right, right. What happened there? They were so good about structuring the show and what needed to be in and what, what was, might have been really funny, but didn't help. Right. Or might have explained a whole backstory. Right. But they just, they let the audience just jump in the middle. They didn't have to like explain everything. But every once in a while,
是的。但它们都太棒了。你知道的，剪辑师和格雷格，我从不为任何被从剧中删掉的东西感到后悔。我对他们充满信心，因为你知道有些人会有占有欲，比如，“好吧，那场戏为什么被删了？对啊。那里发生了什么？”他们在构建剧情方面做得太好了，知道什么必须保留，什么虽然可能非常搞笑但并没有什么帮助。对啊。或者可能解释了整个背景故事。对啊。但他们只是让观众直接切入中间。他们不需要解释一切。但每隔一段时间，
as we're doing this rewatch and we find a deleted scene or something that's such a nugget. We're like, oh, that's why he would come in these costumes and give a big presentation. It's because of Hoot, The Owl. Did you get to give notes on things? Like, were you very much a part of that? Like, I would remember sometimes you would stay behind after a table read and they would want to know your thoughts and things. They were really collaborative and open in that way, right? For sure. Yes.
当我们重温这部剧，发现一个删减片段或者类似这样的珍宝时。我们就会想：“哦！这就是为什么他会穿着这些服装进来做个大演说。”是因为猫头鹰呼呼。你有机会对事情提出意见吗？比如，你很大程度上参与其中吗？就像，我有时会记得你在围读剧本后留下来，他们想知道你的想法之类的事情。他们在那种事情上真的很有合作精神也很开放，对吧？肯定的。是的。
And the fact that so many of the writers were also, actors on the show. There was such a great connection that it didn't feel like different facets of the show. Again, everybody just felt like they were all collaborators. And the writers were part of the ensemble, which I think helped because they understood everyone's voice that much better because they were there and they were hearing it. But yeah, I mean, I'd weigh in. Would you pitch ideas?
而且许多编剧本身也是剧中的演员这一事实。这种极好的联系使得它不像是剧集的各个不同方面。再次重申，每个人都只觉得自己是合作者。编剧们也是演员阵容的一部分，我认为这很有帮助，因为他们更了解每个人的声音，因为他们就在现场，而且他们听得到。但是的，我的确会发表意见。你会提出自己的想法吗？
Sure, yeah. Do you remember any? Well, I remember once specifically, and this was later on, this was when you and Jim were getting married. And they wanted to have a horse go over Niagara Falls. Oh, my gosh. And I raised my hand and said, we can't. That's crazy. I mean, I'll do respect, but please don't do that.
当然，会的。你还记得什么吗？嗯，我确实记得有一次，那是后来的事了，那是你和吉姆结婚的时候。他们想让一匹马冲过尼亚加拉大瀑布。哦，天哪。然后我举起手说：“我们不能这么做。这太疯狂了。恕我直言，请千万别这么做。”
It was not just you. Apparently, when we were breaking down that episode, we talked to Greg about it. And he was like, Steve told me not to do it. Randy told me not to do it. You told me not to do it. Like literally everyone told him. It was so hard for him to let go of that. I'm sure if it was Greg, it would have been funny, definitely.
不仅是你一个人。显然，当我们剖析那一集时，我们和格雷格谈过这件事。他说：“史蒂夫叫我别这么做。兰迪叫我别这么做。你也叫我别这么做。”字面意义上每个人都告诉他别这么做。他要放弃这个想法真的很不容易。我敢肯定如果是格雷格来拍，肯定也会挺搞笑的。
And those were rare moments when you felt like, no, I, yeah, I mean, little notes here and there. But again, those writers were so. good and so on point about everything that it was more in addition to as opposed to negating. Yeah. Side note, did you know, we didn't know this. Randy shared this with us that up until like right, like the day before, they had a horse, they were training in a big water pool at Paramount Studios. Like, they were all systems go like right up until like the day before.
而那些都是罕见的时刻，你会觉得：“不，我，是的，我的确会提出一些小意见。”但话说回来，那些编剧太优秀了，对一切的把握都那么准确，所以这更多的是锦上添花，而不是全盘否定。是的。顺便提一句，你知道吗，我们以前不知道这一点。兰迪跟我们分享过，直到大概，就在前一天，他们还弄了一匹马，在派拉蒙制片厂的一个大水池里进行训练。就像，直到前一天他们还在全力以赴地筹备。
There was a horse being trained. Of course there was. That's what you don't realize when you write something, somebody starts to build it. Yeah. I mean, it starts to happen. So when you say, oh, so now we're going to be out in the woods. Yeah. And then a month later, you're driving an hour and a half up into the Los Angeles forest to shoot a few scenes.
有一匹马正在接受训练。当然有。这就是你写剧本时所意识不到的，有人开始着手搭建了。是的。我的意思是，事情开始发生了。所以当你写下：“哦，所以现在我们要去树林里了。”然后一个月后，你得开车一个半小时去洛杉矶的森林里拍几场戏。
Like, why did I write this? Terrible idea. It's nighttime in the forest. The middle of nowhere. Freezing. Yeah. Terrible. He falls in a creek.
你会想：“我为什么要这么写？太糟糕的主意了。森林里是夜里。荒郊野岭的。冷得要命。是的。太糟了。”他掉进了一条小溪里。
What? Why did I write it? So we've talked how the show was slow to find an audience. It was sort of like we were doing a little theater production and no one's seeing it. But then one day it turned a corner and everybody knew the show and we had people coming up to us. Jenna, do you remember we're in an award show and Laura Dern was like, stop, I have to talk to you. And we're like, what? She was like, I love your show.
什么？我为什么要写这个？我们讨论过这部剧是如何慢热地找到观众的。这就好像我们在做一个小型戏剧制作，没有人看。但后来有一天，它迎来了转折点，每个人都知道这部剧了，而且有人认出我们来了。珍娜，你还记得我们在一个颁奖典礼上，劳拉·邓恩突然说：“等等，我必须跟你谈谈。”然后我们想：“什么？”她说：“我超爱你们的剧。”
And I was like, this is Laura Dern? Oh my gosh. But was there anyone like that for you, Steve, that sort of surprised you and caught you off guard that was a fan of the show? Laura Dern. Same thing. I met her somewhere down the road. I was doing a promotional thing with her.
我当时想：“这是劳拉·邓恩吗？”哦，天哪。但对你来说，史蒂夫，有没有谁像这样让你感到惊讶、让你措手不及，而且还是这部剧的粉丝？劳拉·邓恩。同样的情况。我在后来的某个地方遇到了她。我当时在和她一起做一个宣传活动。
And I wasn't even aware of your encounter with her. Because she was clearly a fan because she was very excited to talk about the show. And, you know, she said the same things to me. She loved it. She was a, and that's, it's nice when, you know, it's nice when anyone likes something that you're a part of. and especially nice when somebody that you respect like that and has sort of a critical eye for things likes your show.
我甚至不知道你和她有过这样的偶遇。因为她显然是这部剧的粉丝，她对谈论这部剧感到非常兴奋。而且，你知道的，她对我说了一样的话。她超爱这部剧。她是一个，你知道的，当任何人喜欢你参与的作品时，这感觉总是很好的。尤其是当你尊敬的、对事物有批判性眼光的人喜欢你的剧时，那就更棒了。
So, yeah, it was really nice. It was nice hearing any of it, you know? Because you're right. Early on, it felt like we were in a vacuum. And is any, let alone appreciating, is anyone watching it? Is anyone, you know, paying any sort of attention? And the only part of it that mattered to me was the continuation of the show. I wanted to have enough people watch it so they kept letting us do it.
所以，是的，这真的很好。听到这些感觉都很棒，你知道吗？因为你是对的。早期的时候，感觉我们就像是在真空中。不仅有没有人在欣赏，甚至有没有人在看？有没有人在，你知道的，给予任何形式的关注？而这其中唯一对我重要的事情是这部剧能够延续下去。我希望有足够多的人看它，这样他们才会继续让我们拍下去。
Because I didn't really care about the acclaim. Right. Or like, we knew that we liked it and we were having fun with it. And I think we all felt like it was special in that moment. And that's what mattered to me. But yeah, yeah, it was Laura Dern. I remember that time early on because a few of us had gotten on MySpace. and we were able to interact with the like 17 people who were watching our show in the beginning.
因为我并不是真的很在意赞誉。或者说，我们知道我们喜欢它，而且我们在其中玩得很开心。我想我们所有人都觉得那一刻它是特别的。这对我来说才是最重要的。但是的，是的，就是劳拉·邓恩。我记得早期那段时光，因为我们当中有几个人注册了MySpace，
And they were such fans and they so got it and they so appreciated it. And that really like kind of, that just felt so good. You know, because when you make a television show, you don't hear the people laugh when they watch it. And you don't know how it's being received or a movie or whatever, I guess, unless you sneak in the theater. But you can't like go sneak in people's living rooms while they watch it. So I always loved when someone told us that they loved it, especially a fellow artist. And they were excited, too, because the show was different with the documentary style and the looking at the camera. Would you look into the camera after you got jobs on the office?
我们能够与刚开始观看我们节目的那大约17个人进行互动。他们是那么忠实的粉丝，他们是那么懂它、那么欣赏它。这真的让人感觉太棒了。你知道的，因为当你制作一部电视节目时，你听不到人们观看时的笑声。你不知道它是如何被接受的，电影也是如此，我想，除非你偷偷溜进影院。但你不能潜入人们的客厅去看他们观看节目。所以我总是很喜欢有人告诉我们他们有多喜欢它，尤其是同行的艺术家。而且他们也很兴奋，因为这部剧通过纪录片的形式和直视镜头呈现，显得与众不同。你在《办公室》里得到工作后，会直视镜头吗？
I have never had a job where I didn't look into the camera at some point. Same. I can't not make the camera a character now. It's such a habit. At least once. Yeah. I'm sure on Foxcatcher, I looked into the camera and went, nope, you cannot comment on what you just did. Because that's not this show.
我从来没有过哪一份工作是没有在某个时刻直视过镜头的。我也是。我现在无法不把镜头当作一个角色。这已经成了一种习惯。至少一次。是的。我敢肯定在《狐狸猎手》里，我也直视过镜头，并且心想：“不，你不能对你刚才做的事发表评论。”因为那不是这部剧。
Yep. Same for me. I actually had a director say, uh, Angela, you just looked right down the barrel. I was like, oh, I'm sorry. I looked to the left or right. It was such a fun kind of discipline. Know who is really good at that right off the bat was Amy Adams. I'll never forget, because it was kind of a learned.
是的。我也是。我甚至有一个导演说过：“呃，安吉拉，你刚才直接看着镜头了。”我当时说：“哦，对不起。我往左或往右看。”这真是一种有趣、独特的纪律。一开始在这方面就很厉害的人是艾米·亚当斯。我永远不会忘记，因为这在剧中算是一种习得的
strength, I think, on the show to figure out the right way to play the camera, to invite the camera in and to make it feel like these people aren't used to the cameras. So you couldn't be too savvy, especially at first. You couldn't play it too well. You needed to have an awareness of it without like having an over-awareness of it. Yes. But I remember when Amy Adams came in to do purse girl. Was that it? Hot girl. Hot girl. She was selling the purse. selling the purse. Yeah. And I remember she just had like this, she was right up to speed with everybody else in terms of how to play the camera. Like it's eavesdropping. I don't know
力量，我想，那就是弄清楚如何正确地运用镜头，邀请镜头进来，让人们觉得这些人并不习惯面对镜头。所以你不能表现得太精明，尤其是一开始。你不能演得太过了。你需要对它有所意识，但又不能表现得过度意识。是的。但我记得艾米·亚当斯来客串“包包女孩”的时候。是那一集吗？“辣妹”。辣妹。她在卖包。卖包。是的。我记得她当时的状态就像，她和其他所有人一样，对于如何利用镜头已经驾轻就熟。就像偷听一样。我不知道
how I should react to it. And that sort of discomfort built in that we had learned how to do. So she was really good at that. And that was such an interesting and we'll never, we'll never get to do something like that again. It was a really interesting acting exercise to be, you know, you're doing, you're in your character and your character is also being watched. So there was like another layer of something going on with all of these characters, which is kind of cool. You mentioned Amy Adams, one of my favorite guest stars that we had in terms of chemistry with you was Tim Meadows. You guys doing the baby back ribs. That also, that episode has one of my favorite, lines in it, which is, Gould is dead.
我该对此作何反应。那种内置的不适感是我们学会如何去表现的。所以她在这方面真的很擅长。那是非常有趣的一次经历，而且我们再也不会有机会做类似的事情了。那是一个非常有趣的表演练习，你知道的，你在演你的角色，而你的角色同时也在被注视着。所以所有这些角色身上都有另一层东西在发生，这真是太酷了。你提到了艾米·亚当斯，我们在节目中遇到的、和你很有化学反应的客串明星中，我最喜欢的一个是蒂姆·梅多斯。你们一起吃烤肋排。那一集里也有我最喜欢的一句
Because Jan is no longer Jan Levinson, Gould. Yeah. And she's like, no, Michael, we got, we're separated. We're divorced. Gould didn't die. As if, as if she would drop the Gould from her name if he died. Right. As a widow.
台词之一，那就是：“古尔德死了。”因为简不再是简·莱文森·古尔德了。是的。然后她说：“不，迈克尔，我们，我们分居了。我们离婚了。古尔德没死。”就好像，就好像如果他死了，她就会把古尔德从她的名字里去掉一样。对吧。作为一个寡妇。
Yeah. Amazing. But yeah, I love you guys. I don't know how you got through all the rib eating and singing and comedy from that episode. I've known Tim for a long time. too. And we did a Second City show that went to Washington, D.C. at the Kennedy Center with Nancy. We went as this group one summer and spent, I don't know, three weeks of the Kennedy Center doing a Second City show.
是的。太惊人了。不过，是的，我太喜欢你们俩了。我不知道你们是怎么熬过那一集里所有的吃肋排、唱歌和喜剧表演的。我认识蒂姆很长时间了。而且我和南希一起在肯尼迪中心和第二城剧团去过华盛顿特区演过第二城剧团的节目。
And I had known him from Second City as well, you know, earlier on stage. And he is so, I think he's one of those, one of those people that is always great. he's never not great. You know, sometimes people like that are under the radar and then they pop out and you say, oh my gosh, like they're incredible. And yeah, he's, I think, one of the best and he's a great improviser. And he's so effortless.
我们有一年夏天作为这个团体去的，不知道，在肯尼迪中心呆了三个星期演第二城剧团的节目。我早年在第二城剧团的舞台上也认识他，你知道的。而且他非常，我认为他是那种无论什么时候都很棒的人。他从来没有不棒的时候。你知道的，有时这样的人会不为人知，然后他们突然爆发，你会说：“哦天哪，他们太不可思议了。”所以，是的，我认为他是最棒的之一，而且他是个很棒的即兴演员。他表现得那么毫不费力。
He just doesn't look like he's ever breaking a sweat and he's hilarious. Yeah, I'm a big fan. He's a great guy. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we have some more questions from the fans. Okay. All right, we're back.
他看起来从不流汗，而且他极其搞笑。是的，我是他的超级粉丝。他是个好人。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？广告回来后，我们还有一些来自粉丝的问题。好的。好了，我们回来了。
And while we were on break, before we get to fan questions, Steve, I remembered this cold open that we did that led in to a talking head that was one sentence from you. When I rewatched it, I laughed so hard. I had tears streaming down my face. What? Do you remember the cold open that we did where we're all trying to take the Christmas photo? Yes. Yes. And we're trying to jump on three, three, two, one, two, three.
在休息期间，在进入粉丝问题之前，史蒂夫，我想起了我们拍过的一个冷场开头，它引出了一个由你说的只有一句话的纪录片访谈。当我重温它时，我笑得太厉害了。我眼泪直流。什么？你还记得我们拍的那个大家都试图拍圣诞全家福的冷场开头吗？是的。是的。我们在尝试数三声一起跳，三、二、一，二、三。
Yeah. This whole thing. Dwight's like, Phyllis didn't jump. Angela didn't jump. Yes. And it's so long, this cold open. And then it cuts to a talking head of Michael. And Michael says, we never got it.
是的。整个过程。德怀特说：“菲利斯没跳。安吉拉没跳。”是的。而且这个冷场开头好长。然后镜头切到了迈克尔的纪录片访谈。迈克尔说：“我们没拍成。”
I, you know what? That cold open is a perfect demonstration of us as an ensemble, I think. Yeah. Because to make it look as bad as it did, took some effort. It did. Like we had to be completely in sync to be that out of sync. Yeah. And everyone jumping at different times.
我，你知道吗？那个冷场开头完美地展示了我们作为一个演员阵容的默契，我觉得。是的。因为要让它看起来那么糟糕，是需要费一番功夫的。确实如此。我们必须配合得天衣无缝，才能表现得如此步调不一致。是的。每个人都在不同的时间跳。
Yeah. And Michael getting frustrated like a dad would. Like, come on, come on, guys. I think that's a perfect example of how in sync we were as a cast. Because we all got what that thing was. Yeah. And how many people needed to be going at one time. But we didn't talk about it.
是的。而且迈克尔像个父亲一样感到沮丧。就像：“拜托，拜托，伙计们。”我认为这是一个完美的例子，说明我们作为演员阵容是多么的合拍。因为我们都懂那个笑点是什么。是的。而且有多少人需要同时行动。但我们并没有事先商量。
No. We didn't discuss like, well, on the count of three, you two are going to go. And then we just, as a group, we just felt that. And not to give ourselves too big a pat on the back. But I think I've watched that since and thought the same thing. Like, that's, there was something, something cool happening there. That was one of my favorite group cold opens for that reason. I know.
没有。我们没有讨论过“数到三时，你们两个跳”之类的话。我们只是作为一个团体，本能地感受到了。而且并不是为了自我吹捧。但我想我后来回看时也有同感。那就是，那里发生了一些很酷的事情。出于这个原因，那是我最喜欢的集体冷场开头之一。我知道。
Well, let's get into these fan questions. Okay. Catherine G and Christy are both asked If you had to choose a different character To play on the office besides Michael Is there one you'd like to be? Wow, I can't imagine anyone but the people Who played their parts
好了，让我们进入这些粉丝问题吧。好的。凯瑟琳·G和克里斯蒂都问：如果你必须在《办公室》里选择另一个角色来演，除了迈克尔，有没有哪个是你愿意演的？哇，除了演那些角色的人之外，我无法想象任何人。
Right off the top of my head I think Dwight is a very fun role to play But I would have been terrible I mean, rain was perfect for that part So no, I never like I never imagined myself in another part It was just as it should have been. Lauren D. asked, what trend or big pop culture moment that's happened since 2011 do you think Michael would have gotten obsessed about?
直觉告诉我，我认为德怀特是一个非常有趣的、值得去演的角色。但我肯定演得很烂。我的意思是，雷恩简直是那个角色的不二人选。所以不，我从来，我从没想象过自己演其他角色。它就该是那个样子，无可替代。劳伦·D问：你觉得自从2011年以来发生的哪个流行文化大事件会让迈克尔痴迷不已？
For example, Lauren thinks Michael would have been all over the ice bucket challenge. Oh, yeah. I think she's absolutely right. So much, so much ice water. Oh, and would have done something wrong. Someone might have ended up in the hospital. Probably Meredith. Right. Yeah.
例如，劳伦认为迈克尔会对冰桶挑战趋之若鹜。哦，是的。我觉得她绝对猜对了。太多、太多的冰水了。哦，而且他肯定会把事情搞砸。可能会有人因此住进医院。可能是梅迪思。对。是的。
Dwight would have overdone it, too. Yes. See, yeah, it would have gone south somehow. It would have gone wrong. We say that we think that Michael probably would have made us all learn TikTok dances. Oh, sure. So many TikTok dances. Yeah.
德怀特也会做得过头。是的。你看，是的，最后肯定会以某种方式走向失控。肯定会出问题的。我们说我们觉得迈克尔很可能会逼着我们所有人都去学TikTok舞蹈。哦，当然。会有数不清的TikTok舞蹈。是的。
Well, the internet wasn't as certainly as much of a thing. Social media really. Yeah. We had flip phones when we started the show. Then we got BlackBerry's. And then at the end, we had iPhones. Yeah, yeah, a lot, a lot changed. Yeah, there are tons of things that Michael would have glommed on to in the worst possible way.
好吧，当时互联网还没有那么普及。社交媒体也是。对啊。我们刚开始做这个节目的时候还用的是翻盖手机。然后我们换了黑莓。最后，我们用上了iPhone。对，对，很多事情都变了。对，迈克尔肯定会以最糟糕的方式迷上无数的东西。
Beth M. writes in and says, what is the most common Michael line that people quote back to you? What do you think it is? Yeah, Beth, that's what she said. Is there one other than that? Um, that's the one, that's the one, that's the one I hear. Yeah. And sometimes, I don't know, do people ever stop you and say, oh, could you talk to, can you do a shout out, you know, into my phone? And yeah.
贝丝·M.发信来问，大家最常引用迈克尔的哪句台词？你们觉得是哪句？对，贝丝，就是那句“她说的”。除了这句还有别的吗？嗯，就是这句，就是这句，这是我经常听到的。对。有时候，我不知道，人们会不会突然拦住你然后说，哦，你能对着我的手机说两句，你知道的，打个招呼吗？会啊。
And I'm happy to do it. But when they say, can you say that, I can't, I just, I don't, I can't. It can be taken out of context. Please don't make Steve say that's what she said. If you see him at the airport. Do you ever, that's what she said in your life, do you ever find? Never. No. Really? I don't do it. I do throw them out. Jenna does. I do. Yeah. Well, you can. You can.
我很乐意这么做。但当他们说“你能说那句话吗”，我不能，我就是，我办不到，我真的说不出口。这可能会被断章取义。请别让史蒂夫说“她说的”这句话。如果你在机场偶遇他。你在生活中会说“她说的”这句话吗？你有没有发现自己说过？从来没有。没有。真的吗？我不用。珍娜会用。我用。对。好吧，你可以的。你可以的。
Gosh, it's going to be so weird when we give you your parting gift. It's a, it's a t-shirt that says that's what she's. Wow. You'll love it. I do wear that all the time. And then on the back it says, I'm fantastic. Same brain. We really liked this question because, we both come from a long line of teachers. Someone wanted to know if you remember a favorite teacher. There was one at particular, a guy named Mr. Blackman, my second grade teacher, and he's the one who got me interested in acting in the first place. We were doing like a Pilgrims Meet the Native Americans thing.
天哪，等我们送你离别礼物时一定会觉得超级奇怪。那是一个T恤，上面写着“那是她说的”。哇。你会喜欢的。我真的经常穿那个。然后背面写着，我太棒了。同一个大脑。我们真的很喜欢这个问题，因为我们俩都出身于教师世家。有人想知道你们是否还记得某个最喜欢的老师。确实有一位，一个叫布莱克曼先生的人，我的二年级老师，他是我对表演产生兴趣的领路人。我们当时在排演一个类似“清教徒与美洲原住民相遇”的小短剧。
It was a long time ago. So a lot was being glossed over for sure. But what I remember is we were rowing canoes. And it was all mime. You know, we were sitting in little chairs in the classroom. It wasn't a big play. It was just like an in-class thing. And I started rowing the canoe, my mime rowing,
那是很久以前的事了。所以很多细节肯定都被一带而过了。但我记得当时我们在划独木舟。而且全都是哑剧。你知道的，我们坐在教室的小椅子上。这不是什么大型戏剧。只是班级里的一个小活动。然后我开始划独木舟，用哑剧划船，
and then I changed my hands with the oar and rode on the other side. I'll never forget it. He singled me out. It's the first time I'd ever been singled out in any way. And he gave me a pat on the back and said, notice how Steve rode on both sides of the canoe so we wouldn't go in a circle. And he kept the canoe straight, you know, in this mime, you know, miming the canoe.
接着我换了拿船桨的手势，开始在另一边划。我永远不会忘记这件事。他把我单独叫了出来。这是我生平第一次在任何方面被单独表扬。他拍拍我的背说，大家看史蒂夫是怎么在独木舟的两侧划船的，这样我们就不会原地转圈了。而且他把独木舟保持得很直，你知道的，在这场哑剧中，你知道的，是在假装划独木舟。
And something about that really struck me. And I thought, and apart from that, he was just the most lovely guy and really kind to all the kids and everyone, it was fun. It was really just a fun class. And he did that for all the kids too. He made them feel special about whatever talent they had, whether it was art or music or anything. He really embraced, you know, everyone's abilities, you know, as that.
这件事触动了我内心深处的某个地方。我想，抛开这些不谈，他真的是个极好的人，对所有的孩子和所有人都很友善，这很有趣。这真的是一个很有趣的班级。他对所有的孩子都是这样的。他让大家觉得，无论自己有什么才华，不管是艺术、音乐还是别的什么，都是很特别的。他真的包容了所有人的能力，你知道的，
little as they were in that moment as a second grader. But I'll never forget it. Like being seen. Yeah. Yeah. You don't see. Yeah. And it was, it was, that was special. Something sort of clicked. Like, oh, that felt good. And so I guess I owe it all they am. You know, Steve, I love that story because I have a similar story. I took a summer school acting class and we had to do panam. We had to mime things. And my assignment was to go over to the refrigerator and get out some milk and pour in a glass and drink it. And so I did it. And afterwards, the teacher said, did everyone notice how Jenna shut the refrigerator with her foot? Oh. Yeah. It's exactly. And I was like, wait, I might be good at this because I didn't think it just, maybe I have a little thing. Right. Exactly. You know,
尽管当时我们作为二年级学生还很懵懂。但我永远不会忘记那种感觉。就像被看见了一样。对。对。你不会被忽视。对。而且，那真的很特别。内心某处仿佛“咔哒”一声被点亮了。就好像，哦，感觉真好。所以我想我能有今天都要归功于他。你知道的，史蒂夫，我特别喜欢这个故事，因为我也有过类似的经历。我上过一个暑期表演课，我们需要练习模仿。我们必须用哑剧表演。我的作业是走到冰箱前，拿出一小杯牛奶，倒进玻璃杯然后喝掉。于是我照做了。做完后，老师说，大家注意到珍娜是用脚关冰箱门的吗？哦。对。就是这样。当时我想，等等，我可能挺有天赋的，因为我根本没多想，也许我就是有点这方面的灵感。对。没错。你知道的，
and then it just makes you feel like I might be good at this. Or it might be something. Yeah. You know, it might be something that I'm actually, yeah, capable of. That's so fun. And it's not even like, look at me. No. It's just a sense of a set, like one of the first senses of pride that you ever feel. Yes. That you accomplish something completely on your own, not your parents, and nothing that you were instructed to do.
然后这就会让你觉得，我或许真的很擅长这个。或者这可能是个方向。对。你知道的，这也许正是我真正擅长并且能做好的事情。太有趣了。这甚至不是那种“快看我”的感觉。不。这只是一种最初获得的自豪感。是的。你完全靠自己完成了一件事，不是靠父母，也不是按照别人的指示去做的。
It's just something that you did naturally. And to have somebody notice it felt really good. And that's a great teacher in my mind. Somebody who can pick up on those things. Yeah. Okay. I love this question. Here it is.
这完全是你自然而然做出来的。而且能被别人注意到，感觉真的很好。在我看来，这就是一位好老师。一个能捕捉到这些细节的人。好吧。我很喜欢这个问题。问题是这样的。
Are there any foods you don't eat anymore because of so many takes you had to do with that certain food? It can be on the office or any other job. I know mine right away. It's that cake that we had to eat, the ice cream cake for Meredith's birthday. Was it the Alliance? We started filming at 7.30 in the morning and we were given a slice of cake. And, you know, this is a rookie move on my part. I took a plate with a big piece of cake and I took a huge bite in that first take.
有没有什么食物，因为拍戏时要拍太多条而导致你再也不想吃了？可以是在《办公室》剧组，也可以是在其他剧组。我立刻就能想到我的那个。就是我们吃的那块蛋糕，梅雷迪思生日时吃的冰淇淋蛋糕。是那个联盟集吗？我们早上七点半开始拍摄，然后每人分到了一块蛋糕。而且，你知道的，这是我的菜鸟行为。我拿了一个盘子，上面有一大块蛋糕，在第一条拍摄时我就咬了一大口，
and by the end my fork was shaking as it got close to my mouth because I was like, I can't, I can't eat it anymore. Anyway, I was asking you that, but clearly I have a visceral, like, I can't eat ice cream cake anymore. That did it. That did you in. Yeah, it's so gross to me. I learned early on to nibble.
结果到了最后，当叉子靠近嘴边时我的手都在抖，因为我在想，我真的吃不下了，我再也吃不下了。总之，本来我是想问你的，但很显然，我对冰淇淋蛋糕产生了生理性排斥，再也吃不下去了。那次彻底把你打败了。可不是吗。对，我觉得太恶心了。我从一开始就吸取了教训，要小口小口地吃。
Yeah. Not like if that first take, try not to take a big bite because then you have to match it for the rest of the day. Every time. Yeah. Or I'm. I'm not hungry today. You know, my character's not hungry. But Michael would eat some pretty crazy stuff.
对。如果在第一条拍摄时，尽量不要咬太大口，因为接下来一整天你都得保持连戏。每一次都是这样。对。或者我就说，我今天不饿。你知道的，我扮演的角色现在不饿。但迈克尔会吃一些相当疯狂的东西。
Nothing that turned my stomach, nothing to the point where I can't eat it anymore. I did a bit on The Daily Show where I was supposed to be eating Crisco. I was doing, it was some health food segment. And I said, well, this is all vegetable-based. And I was like at the desk with John. And so I take a big spoonful of Crisco.
没有哪样让我觉得反胃到再也不想碰的地步。我在《每日秀》里拍过一个桥段，当时我得吃克里斯科起酥油。我在做，那是一个健康食品环节。我说，嗯，这全都是植物性的。我和乔恩一起坐在办公桌旁。然后我就用勺子挖了厚厚一大勺克里斯科塞进嘴里。
For real, Crisco? Well, they wanted to mock it up and just put vanilla frosting in because no one would know. And I could play it like it's Crisco. But I said, no, leave Crisco in because that's going to be funnier for John to watch me, Chrisco, because the expression on his face was pretty horrified. And I didn't practice it. So I didn't know what I was getting myself into. And so on camera, basically live, you know, that shows.
真的吃克里斯科？好吧，他们本想用香草糖霜来做道具，因为没人会发现。我也可以假装那是克里斯科。但我说，不，就用真的克里斯科吧，因为让乔恩看着我吃克里斯科会更有趣，而且他脸上的表情也确实非常惊恐。我之前没有排练过。所以我根本不知道自己要面对的是什么。所以在镜头前，基本上是现场直播，你知道的那种节目。
live to tape, but it was really bad. I did not. I could, I mean, the two of us had a hard time getting through the rest of that segment because he knew. He knew I was in your eyes. He did. He knew I was in distress. So, so not that I would sit around eating Criscoe, but that kind of, that was a hard one.
虽然是录播，但当时真的太难受了。我完全不行。我是说，我们俩接下来拍那个环节都费了好大劲，因为他知道。他从我的眼神里看出我知道了。他确实知道。他知道我正在受折磨。所以，倒不是说我会坐在那儿吃克里斯科，但那种经历，真的是个巨大的挑战。
Yeah. Here's a good question. Do you have a Toby in your life? Someone who just enrages you the second. This was one of our favorite questions sent in. Because we're like, we're sure Steve doesn't have a toebeat, but yeah. Someone who just really for no reason. You just hate.
对。这里有个好问题。你的生活中也有托比这样的人吗？就是那种一出现就让你怒火中烧的家伙。这是我们收到的最受欢迎的问题之一。因为我们在想，史蒂夫肯定没有讨厌的人吧，但也许有。就是那种莫名其妙就让你觉得很烦的人。
Just abject hatred. No, I don't. But that's one of my favorite character dynamics of the time that I spent on the office. And it evolved from, I don't exactly. it's been discussed as to, and I think the writers could sort of pinpoint clearly. But I think one day I just decided, I just got really mad at him and like disgusted by him for no reason. And we just kind of stayed with it. People lost it.
纯粹的讨厌。不，我没有。但这是我在《办公室》度过的时光里最喜欢的角色关系之一。而且这种关系的发展，我不确定具体原因。大家也讨论过，我想编剧们可能能准确指出原因。但我猜有一天我只是突然决定，对他感到非常生气，而且毫无理由地对他感到厌恶。然后我们就顺着这个方向演下去了。大家每次都笑疯了。
They would lose it at a table read when you would snap it, Toby. We did an interview with Paul and he said he remembers the moment. Oh, he does? It was during the alliance when he has to come in the office and sign Meredith's birthday card. And apparently it just took him a long time. Right. And you turned on him. And you told him, you said, I don't know what it is, Paul, but I hate you for how long it's taken you to write this card.
每当你在剧本围读时对托比发飙，大家都会笑得人仰马翻。我们采访过保罗，他说他还记得那一刻。哦，是吗？那是在“联盟”那一集里，他必须走进办公室在梅雷迪思的生日卡上签字。显然他磨蹭了很久。对。然后你就冲他发火了。你对他说，我不知道为什么，保罗，但我恨死你写张卡片居然要磨蹭这么久。
And you guys laughed so hard about it. And you met like me as Michael. Like Michael is so irritated with you right now. and that that was like... Everyone else just signed their name. But he started to write something. Yeah. I love the fact that it was never discussed, too, as to why and the specifics of it.
你们当时为这个笑得前仰后合。你的意思是作为迈克尔的我——就像迈克尔当时对你超级不耐烦一样。然后这就变成了…… 大家都只是签了名字。但他却开始写长篇大论。对。我也很喜欢这一点，那就是我们从来没有讨论过原因以及其中的具体细节。
Yeah. And people have asked me that, too, well, why does Michael hate Toby so much? And I think, well, I think it's like the end when our characters say goodbye to each other, I'll never talk about exactly what was said, because that's like our thing. And it's more fun, too, to leave those things as sort of a mystery. Like, well, why really? Because I built in Michael's head, like, all of the reasons. But it's better that you don't know.
对，大家也经常问我这个问题，迈克尔为什么那么讨厌托比？我想，嗯，我觉得就像最后我们的角色互相告别时那样，我永远不会透露当时具体说了什么，因为那是属于我们之间的秘密。而且把这些东西留作某种悬念，其实更有趣。比如说，真正的原因到底是什么呢？因为我在迈克尔的脑海里构建了所有的理由。但由你不知道这些，效果反而更好。
Yeah. That it just kind of sits there. That's how I feel about the teapot letter. Right. Everyone wants to know what's in the teapot letter. And the thing is, is that what's in the teapot letter is what you need to be in the teapot letter. Yeah. There's what I needed to be in the teapot letter.
对。就让它那样悬着。我对茶壶信也是这种感觉。对吧。每个人都想知道茶壶信里写了什么。但关键在于，茶壶信里写的内容，正是你需要它写的内容。对。那是我需要的茶壶信。
There's the thing that Pam needs. but like it has to be the most wonderful romantic thing and you can't write it like you can't tell people what was in it. It'll just be a letdown. It will. It can't live up to it, right? So it's like, I know what it said. Completely. But it's better if you write it yourself as an audience member. I think the writers in general felt that way about the show. And I think Greg was very savvy about that. You don't have to tell the whole story and just let people come to it. And I think that's partly why people have liked the show over the years. It doesn't spell everything out about these characters or about these relationships. You kind of acquire a knowledge over time, and it becomes
那是吉姆送给帕姆的。但它必须是最浪漫美好的事情，你不能写出来，你不能告诉别人里面写了什么。那样只会让人失望。确实会。它无法承载所有的期待，对吧？所以就像是，我知道信里写了什么。完全明白。但作为观众，你自己去想象它会更好。我觉得编剧们对这部剧的总体看法也是这样的。而且我觉得格雷格在这方面非常有远见。你不需要把整个故事全盘托出，只需让观众自己去体会。我想这也是为什么多年来人们一直喜欢这部剧的部分原因。它没有把关于这些角色或这些关系的一切都明说出来。随着时间的推移，你会慢慢积累一种认知，而这种认知会变得
more ingrained that way. This is sort of off the subject, but you know, you're talking about the teapot letter. And, you know, and I've thought about this many, many times since I left the show, that you and John, in my opinion, you and John were the rock of that show. You know, the rock of that show. show. Like, if not for your two characters, I feel like that show would have imploded because there was so much craziness going on and so much wackiness. And you were both such grounded characters on that show while simultaneously being incredibly funny and real. But the fact that everyone could bounce off of you and you're very grounded, loving and interesting relationship and how that grew.
更加根深蒂固。这虽然有点题外话，但你知道的，你们刚才在谈论茶壶信。而且，自我离开剧组以来，我很多很多次都想过，在我看来，你和约翰，你们俩是这部剧的顶梁柱。你知道的，这部剧的中流砥柱。如果没有你们两个角色，我觉得这部剧早就分崩离析了，因为里面有太多疯狂和古怪的事情。而在同时展现出令人难以置信的幽默和真实感的同时，你们俩在这部剧中又是如此脚踏实地的角色。但事实是，每个人都能从你们身上得到反弹，你们那段非常扎实、充满爱意且引人入胜的关系以及它是如何不断发展的。
To me, that was the nucleus of the show. I've always felt that way. And the way that you guys, and you're both such good actors too, it's like we were just so fortunate on so many fronts in terms of the casting of this show, in terms of the writing, I attribute it to, well, to you guys, obviously, and to Greg for like putting this group of people together in just the right sort of alchemy.
对我来说，那是这部剧的核心。我一直都是这么觉得的。而且你们俩，你们两个又是如此优秀的演员，就好像我们在方方面面都太幸运了，无论是这部剧的选角，还是剧本，我都要把这归功于，嗯，当然是归功于你们，还有格雷格，他把这群人以恰到好处的化学反应聚集在了一起。
I don't know if I ever specifically told you that, but I've always felt that way. Steve, thank you. I remember when we got ready to shoot the pilot, Stephen and Ricky came to visit and we had like this one day meeting with them. And Stephen told John and I, never forget you two are the heart of the show. And I remember it was like in threat level midnight, I was like gulp, gulp. I thought, I don't really know what that means. That's sort of scary to me. I was sort of hoping to kind of keep with my whole like wallflower thing where Pam just kind of
我不知道我是否曾对你特意说过这话，但我一直都是这种感觉。史蒂夫，谢谢你。我记得当我们准备拍摄试播集时，史蒂芬和瑞奇来探班，我们和他们开了一天的会。史蒂芬告诉我和约翰，永远不要忘记，你们俩才是这部剧的心脏。我还记得当时在《午夜威胁等级》里，我忍不住咽了好大一口口水。我想，我其实不太明白那是什么意思。这对我来说有点吓人。我当时其实更希望能保持我那种壁花女孩的风格，就是帕姆那种
sits at the desk and gives a couple of stairs really liking that lane. But over time, I understood what he meant. And it's kind of what you're saying, which is like, we're not going to go to you all the time or maybe even very often, but over a large arc, over a large period of time, this is a really important thing. And so just, you know, make sure you always honor it. Make sure that you, you know that you honor that. And I'm so glad we did. I'm so glad Jim and Pam made it and work. And they didn't like do that thing where they pull you apart and put you back together. The breakup, makeup, makeup. Yeah. And I get really defensive Jim and Pam.
坐在桌子后面，偶尔投去几个眼神，我挺喜欢那种戏份的。但随着时间的推移，我明白了他说的话是什么意思。这就有点像你刚才说的，也就是，我们不会一直把镜头对准你们，甚至可能不会经常这么做，但在整个长篇故事弧光中，在一个漫长的时间跨度里，这是一个非常重要的存在。所以，你知道的，确保你始终尊重它。确保你，你知道的，去珍视这一点。我很高兴我们做到了。我很高兴吉姆和帕姆最后修成了正果。他们没有走那种把他们拆散又重新撮合的老套路。分分合合，分分合合。对。而且我对吉姆和帕姆极其护短。
If we're doing an interview and someone's like to Jenna, I think Jim and Pam are still together. I'm like, how dare you? Of course they're still together. And so are Dwight and Angela and so are Michael and Holly. Get out of here. Oh, you know what? I need to tell you about.
如果我们正在接受采访，有人对珍娜说，我觉得吉姆和帕姆现在还在一起。我就会想，你怎么敢这么说？他们当然还在一起。德怀特和安吉拉也是，迈克尔和霍莉也是。少来这套。哦，你知道吗？我得跟你说件事。
No. Oh, dear. No. About Michael and Holly. No. No. Oh, it is bad. I don't want to get into it.
不。哦，天哪。不。关于迈克尔和霍莉的。不。不。哦，这太糟糕了。我不想深究。
We just watch the scene and it's, you know, I feel like I'm rediscovering so many of these scenes because we haven't seen the show since it aired, you know, a lot of these episodes. But when you and Amy Ryan do that, you are, hoo-ha, like that moment. And it says basically, I love you. Like, yo, it's like, I was like tearing up. Yeah. I, like, played it for Jenna. I was like, you got to watch the scene.
我们刚看了那个场景，你知道的，我觉得我正在重新发现许多这样的场景，因为自从剧集播出后，我们已经很久没看过这部剧了，你知道的，很多集都没看过。但当你和艾米·瑞安演那个片段时，你们俩，天哪，就那个时刻。那台词基本上就是在说，我爱你。就像是，我当时都要哭了。对。我，就像把它放给珍娜看一样。我说，你必须看看这个场景。
They're just saying you are, but it's like so powerful. Yeah, Amy Ryan's pretty good. Yeah, she's okay. She was fine. I mean, eh, yeah. I guess we were lucky to get her in the show. She did pretty well for herself, I think. Yeah, fantastic.
他们只是在说你是，但那感觉太有力量了。对，艾米·瑞安真的很棒。对，她还行。她挺好的。我是说，呃，对。我想我们能请她来演这部剧真的很幸运。我觉得她把自己经营得很好。对，太棒了。
We did just watch all of these episodes. We watched the proposal to Holly and the singing goodbye to you. Yeah. And, you know, all the individual goodbyes to all the different people. What a brutal couple of final weeks for you. I mean, were we, did we just cry the whole time? How did we do that? I don't know.
我们刚才确实把所有这些集都看了一遍。我们看了向霍莉求婚的那段，还有唱《再见》的那段。对。而且，你知道的，所有针对不同角色的个人告别。对你来说，最后这几周简直是一段残酷的时光。我是说，我们，我们是不是从头哭到尾？我们是怎么熬过来的？我不知道。
You know, I could look at it that I'm, I don't know. I don't want to make too much of it. But it was, it was difficult because, you know, we were such good friends and it had been so much fun. Mm-hmm. And so rewarding in a lot of ways, all ways. But at the same time, there was this, for me, there was a joy to it. You know, when you, you're crying with joy. Because it wasn't even sadness, like, because I was ready.
你知道的，我可以这样看待它，我，我不知道。我不想把它夸大其词。但确实，这很艰难，因为，你知道的，我们是那么好的朋友，而且这段经历太有趣了。嗯哼。在很多方面，在所有方面都收获满满。但与此同时，对我来说，其中也有一种快乐。你知道的，当你喜极而泣的时候。因为甚至都不是那种悲伤，因为我已经准备好了。
I was ready to go. and so I wasn't sad about leaving. Yeah. And it felt right for Michael. Yeah. No, it was time. And it was time for other characters to kind of step to the forefront and other storylines to be pursued.
我已经准备好离开了。所以我并不为离开感到难过。对。而且我觉得这对迈克尔来说很合适。对。不，时机刚刚好。是时候让其他角色走到聚光灯下来，去发展其他的故事线了。
It was just, I think it was the right. It was the timing was right. I think for everybody. But simultaneously, there's just a sense of joy for me that we had experienced all of this. And we were getting, I was getting a chance. to kind of take a lap with everybody. And the way, you know, those last few episodes were structured, it felt very rich to me to kind of simultaneously be saying goodbye as Michael and, you know,
这只是，我觉得这是对的。时机刚刚好。对每个人来说都是如此。但与此同时，对我而言，心中只有一种喜悦，因为我们曾经共同经历过这一切。而且我得到了，我有机会。和大家一起完成最后一段旅程。而且你知道的，最后这几集的结构安排，对我来说感觉非常丰富，既作为迈克尔在说再见，你知道的，
us as friends, you know, in this moment of work together. But yeah, it was a lot. It was a very emotional thing. It was. Like, it was. It was just hitting us in waves, I remember. Like, we would laugh one minute and then we'd be tearing up the next. But like you said, it's because we had had such a great run.
而我们作为朋友，在共同工作的时刻。但是，是的，这真的感慨万千。这是一件非常情绪化的事。确实如此。就像是，我记得那种情绪一阵接一阵地涌上心头。我们上一秒还在大笑，下一秒就要落泪了。但就像你说的，那是因为我们有过一段如此美妙的经历。
We'd had such a good time. Incredible. Just incredible. Steve, we are always telling people when they ask us, what was it like to work with Steve Correll? What is Steve Correll like? And we say he is a regular guy. We're telling you he is a regular guy.
我们度过了一段如此美好的时光。不可思议。简直不可思议。史蒂夫，每当人们问我们，“和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作是什么感觉？”“史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是个怎样的人？”我们总是告诉他们，他就是一个普通人。我们告诉过你，他就是一个普通人。
Yeah. So we thought we would end this interview with a regular guy quiz. Yeah. All right. All right. Regular guy question number one. Favorite pizza? Favorite brand of pizza?
对。所以我们觉得应该用一个“普通人快问快答”来结束这次采访。对。好吧。好吧。普通人问题一。最喜欢的披萨？最喜欢的披萨品牌？
like favorite pizza place. Oh my gosh. You're very versed in pizza. I mean, oh, come on. We know your love of pizza. Well. Favorite topping? I will either go with just a plain cheese or maybe do half cheese and then half mushroom and pepperoni.
就像最喜欢的披萨店。哦，天哪。你对披萨很有研究啊。我是说，噢，拜托。我们都知道你对披萨的热爱。好吧。最喜欢的配料？我要么点纯芝士的，要么一半芝士，另一半加蘑菇和意式辣香肠。
That's my pizza of choice. Okay. But I have a lot of different spots. I have different types, the deep dish, the thin crust, the New York style. There's different L.A. types of pizzas that are, it's, I'm sort of a connoisseur. Next podcast, pizza with Steve. That's, hey, you just gave me an idea.
这就是我的首选披萨。好吧。但我有很多不同的店。我有不同类型的披萨，深盘披萨、薄脆披萨、纽约风格。洛杉矶还有各种不同类型的披萨，我算是个行家了。下一个播客，跟史蒂夫一起吃披萨。那个，嘿，你刚才给了我一个灵感。
I'm getting the studio next to yours. Next question, favorite ice cream or frozen yogurt. I like a good, uh, I kind of a basic, like a chocolate. Mm-hmm. I like a good Sunday, like a hot fudge Sunday. Okay. It's always pretty delicious. So you like a top.
我要在你的录音室旁边也租个工作室。下一个问题，最喜欢的冰淇淋或冻酸奶。我喜欢好的，呃，我比较喜欢基础款，比如巧克力味。嗯哼。我喜欢好的圣代，比如热法式奶油糖浆圣代。好吧。总是非常美味的。所以你喜欢顶部加料。
being more than maybe something in the actual ice cream. I'm not, yeah. Brownies mixed in are always good. Okay. But kind of basic. Kind of, I don't, I'm not like a gummy worms and pistachio ice cream kind of guy. That sounds delicious. Okay.
多过冰淇淋本身自带的东西。我不是，对。混合布朗尼总是很好吃的。好吧。但挺基础的。差不多吧，我可不是那种喜欢吃酸软糖和开心果冰淇淋的人。听起来很美味。好吧。
Let's see. Favorite place you've visited in the United States? Pittsburgh was pretty cool. Oh, yeah? Yeah. I mean, I'm not. saying that ironically either. I've done a couple of movies there and I liked it. It was a cool city. All right. There you go. I bet that's the first one you got. Shout out to Pittsburgh.
让我想想。你在美国去过的最喜欢的地方？匹兹堡挺酷的。哦，是吗？对啊。我是说，我不是。在讽刺。我在那里拍过几部电影，我很喜欢那里。那是个很酷的城市。好吧。给你。我敢打赌这是你第一个想到的地方。向匹兹堡致敬。
Shout out to Pittsburgh. What is your least favorite exercise or the exercise you avoid the most? Abs. Yes. Abs. Of course. Oh. Leg day. It was always fun. We love a leg day. Who doesn't? I mean, look at us. I mean, look at us. I like that. Well, yeah. I mean, just. doing sit-ups is that's a, I do it, but I don't love it. Mm-hmm. All right. What's the last thing you bought at Target?
向匹兹堡致敬。你最不喜欢的运动是什么？或者说你最想逃避的运动？腹肌训练。是的。腹肌。当然。哦。练腿日。其实一直挺有意思的。我们都很喜欢练腿日。谁不喜欢呢？我是说，看看我们。我是说，看看我们。我喜欢这样。好吧，对。我是说，只是。做仰卧起坐那简直是个，我虽然做，但并不爱做。嗯哼。好吧。你在塔吉特（Target）买的最后一样东西是什么？
I bought one of those little razors for my son, because he's, he's shaving now. Uh-huh. And it's not, it's like a trimmer. Uh-huh. But it's what, it's what the youths are using now. Okay. They're not, they're not using a blade. We're not there yet.
我给我儿子买了一个那种小剃须刀，因为他现在，他开始刮胡子了。嗯哼。那不是，那其实是个修剪器。嗯哼。但这就是年轻人现在用的那种。好吧。他们不用，他们不用刀片。我们还没到那个阶段。
They're not using. But it's like you can trim it close enough. Uh-huh. This is a terror. You can definitely lift this from the show. No. It's the dumbest answer. I don't even want to know what they're called.
他们不用。但这就好像你可以把它修剪得很干净。嗯哼。这太可怕了。你绝对可以把这段从节目里剪掉。不。这是最蠢的回答。我甚至不想知道它们叫什么。
It's like it's sort of a, I know what you're talking about. It's a little blade and you can kind of. Yeah, like a beard groomer thing. But you can cut it really close but not have to use like an electric razor. And oh, everyone's tuned out. No, everyone's tuned out. No, everyone just changed.
这就好像是一个，我知道你在说什么。就是一个小刀片，你可以稍微。对，就像一个胡须修剪器一样。但你可以把它修剪得很贴皮肤，又不用使用那种电动剃须刀。然后，哦，所有人都走神了。不，所有人都走神了。不，所有人都换成。
change to a different. I want to listen to some music. Go back to pizza. Anyway, the piece. The sweet spot. If you are in charge of cooking dinner, what's your go-to dish? Spaghetti boulinets. Okay.
换去听别的了。我想听点音乐。回到披萨的话题。不管怎样，那块。最完美的部分。如果你负责做晚饭，你的拿手菜是什么？肉酱面。好吧。
I make a pretty good bolognaise sauce. What skill would you like to master? I'd love to learn how to play the piano. Never going to happen. Do you play the piano in any way? No. in any way. So we'd be starting from zero. Totally from zero.
我做的肉酱汁还挺不错的。你最想精通什么技能？我很想学会弹钢琴。永远不可能实现。你会弹钢琴吗？一点也不会。任何形式都不会。所以我们要从零开始。完全从零开始。
Okay. Do you play any instruments? I'm embarrassed. I play the fife and I play the baritone horn. What's a fife? Yeah. Oh, God. Is that like ye oldie, ye oldie flute thing? Yeah. It's exactly right. It's like a, it's like a, you know, okay. Like a, a flute from the 1700s. Pittsburgh and the fife? I didn't think we talked. Not only, am I sort of an ordinary guy, but super boring. Stop it. No.
好吧。你会任何乐器吗？我很尴尬。我会吹横笛，我还会吹巴里东号。什么是横笛？对。哦，天哪。那是那种老掉牙的，中世纪风格的长笛吗？对。完全正确。那就好像是个，你知道的，就好像一个，1700年代的长笛。匹兹堡和横笛？我没想到我们会聊到这。我不但，我算是个普通人，而且超级无聊。够了。不。
Okay, ready to really lean into the boring. How early do you get to the airport before a flight? Like two hours early. That tracks. You were 10 minutes early today. I knew you would be early. And I actually circled the block a few times. I was ready to go, but I'm like, I don't want to seem too eager.
好吧，准备好展现我无聊的一面了。你坐飞机时通常会提前多久到机场？大概提前两小时。这很符合你的风格。你今天早到了10分钟。我就知道你会早到。其实我在街区绕了好几圈。我早就准备好了，但我心想，我可不想显得太急切。
Nancy and I get to the airport so early. And we just We were just talking But it's both of you though You're in sync That's good Totally Okay
南希和我去机场总是特别早。我们只是。我们刚才还在聊天。但你们俩都是这样。你们俩很合拍。那挺好的。完全如此。好吧。
Yes And she's She's often said If she had been married to someone Who is like Always late She would have gotten a divorce
是的。而且她。她经常说。如果她嫁给了一个。总是迟到的人。她早就跟对方离婚了。
Because it would have driven It's very important to her Very Punctuality But for both of us Yes And I would rather sit in the airport For an hour and a half
因为那会把她逼疯的。这对她非常重要。非常讲究准时。但我们俩都是这样。是的。而且我宁愿在机场。坐上一个半小时。
Than be like Getting all worked up in the car That we're going to make Not make our flight All right What is your favorite cocktail or adult beverage? I don't drink a lot. I will occasionally have a glass of wine or something, but I can't say that I have a cocktail. I'm just not a big drinker. We would like to
也不愿像热锅上的蚂蚁一样在车里急得团团转。生怕赶不上航班。好吧。你最喜欢的鸡尾酒或成年人饮料是什么？我不怎么喝酒。我偶尔会喝一杯葡萄酒什么的，但我不能说我有特定最喜欢的鸡尾酒。我本来就不是个大酒鬼。我们想向大家
recommend Michael's drink, which is the Scotch and Splenda. We're not kidding. Here on the show, Steve, it is excellent. It's very good. Really? Yes. Jenna brought it in. No joke. Like as a joke, and I was like, this is going to be disgusting. What are we doing? We made them for everybody. and we were like, damn, it's actually pretty good. I want to order one at a bar, but I'm scared to because. Well, you have to come up with a name for it. Instead of Scotch and Splenda, do you call it a Scotchda? I know.
推荐迈克尔的饮料，也就是苏格兰威士忌加代糖（Scotch and Splenda）。我们没开玩笑。在节目里，史蒂夫，这真的绝了。非常好喝。真的吗？是的。是珍娜带到剧组的。没开玩笑。本来是开玩笑拿出来的，当时我还想，这肯定难喝死了。我们到底在搞什么鬼？我们给每个人都调了一杯。结果我们尝了一口心想，天呐，其实还挺好喝的。我想在酒吧里点一杯，但我又有点不敢，因为。好吧，你得给它起个名字。比起叫“苏格兰威士忌加代糖”，你管它叫“苏格兰代糖鸡尾酒（Scotchda）”怎么样？我知道。
Didn't Michael have a name for it and we can't remember what it is? I don't know. A splotch. Yeah, he does have a name for it. A splotch. Wasn't it a Splenda and Scott? A splotch. A splotch?
迈克尔不是给它起过一个名字吗，我们记不清叫什么了？我不知道。叫“威士忌代糖（Splotch）”。对，他确实给它起了个名字。叫“威士忌代糖”。难道不是叫“代糖威士忌”吗？叫“Splotch”。Splotch？
Maybe a splotch. Oh, that's good. It doesn't sound delicious. It's very. Very good. Yeah. I'll take a splotch, please. You know what?
也许叫Splotch吧。哦，这名字挺好。听起来可不太美味。不过确实。非常好喝。对。请给我来一杯Splotch。你知道吗？
I'll try a splotch at some point. Great. All right. Okay. Next time. The three of us are going to get together. And we're going to have one splotch. We're going to go splotching.
我迟早要尝尝Splotch。太棒了。好吧。下次吧。我们三个人聚在一起。然后我们要一人来一杯Splotch。我们要去喝Splotch了。
Last question. When was the last time you had to get out your toolbox and what tool did you grab? About three days ago. I was putting. I am so embarrassed. Are you about to say you're putting together a bird feeder? Worse. I bought.
最后一个问题。你上一次拿出工具箱是什么时候？用的都是什么工具？大概三天前吧。我在组装。我都觉得太不好意思了。你该不会要说你在组装一个鸟屋吧？更糟。我买了一个。
I bought. I bought a vacuum, an outdoor leaf vacuum, which also mulches the leaves. And I had to go to my toolbox to put it together. I ordered it and it arrived and I had to assemble it and put the little bag on it. Do you blow leaves? Well, I have a leaf blower too. What I do is I use the leaf blower to blow them into a pile. and then I take my vacuum mulcher
我买了一个。我买了一个吸尘器，一个户外落叶吸尘器，它还可以把树叶粉碎。我不得不拿出工具箱来组装它。我网购的，它寄到了，我得把它拼装起来，还要把那个小袋子装上。你会用吹叶机吗？好吧，我也有一个吹叶机。我做的是，我用吹叶机把树叶吹成一堆。然后我拿着我的吸叶粉碎机，
and I vacuum them up and mulch the leaves and then I take the leaves and I put them in our planting beds. Oh my God. And so that's, so the fife. Pittsburgh. Pizza, plain, chocolate ice cream. And that's me, yeah. And we all do it in Pittsburgh.
把它们吸进去，把树叶粉碎，然后我把这些树叶拿来铺在我们的花坛里。哦，天哪。所以这就是，横笛。匹兹堡。素披萨，巧克力冰淇淋。这就是我，对。而且我们都在匹兹堡做这些事。
Beryl of laughs. I'm in love with you. Well, clearly the bar is low because there's not, I can't even believe that Nancy decided to marry me. With like that as a track record, that is the, that's pretty bad. Like when you do interviews like this and you say things and you hear yourself reflected in the words, how you're describing yourself, I think. I'm like more interesting than that. But clearly I'm not. I don't know how to play the piano.
简直笑死我了。我爱死你了。好吧，显然标准很低，因为根本没有，我甚至不敢相信南希竟然决定嫁给我。就凭我这种履历，这实在是，太糟糕了。就像当你接受这样的采访，说出这些话，然后听到这些话回响在耳边时，当你听到自己是如何描述自己的时候，我想。我明明觉得自己比这更有趣。但显然我并没有。我甚至不会弹钢琴。
No. What would you like to do? I'd like to be smart and play the piano. But instead, I'm mulching leaves and playing the fife. So. Okay. Is there anything in your career that you haven't done that you'd like to do or in your life? Because like Jenna, for example.
不。你还想做什么？我想变得聪明点然后学会弹钢琴。但相反，我却在粉碎树叶和吹横笛。所以。好吧。在你的职业生涯中，有什么是你还没做过但想去尝试的吗？或者在你的生活中？因为就像珍娜一样，比如说。
Yes. You know, it is my dream to one day do theater and win a Tony Award. Yes. is my, I would love to do this in my life. My dream is I really want one of those hats that has big flowers on it that hummingbirds eat out of. So that's, Jenna wants to work towards a Tony. I want to work towards a hummingbird eating out of my hat.
是的。你知道的，我一生的梦想就是有一天能去演话剧并赢得一座托尼奖。是的。这就是我，我真的非常渴望在有生之年能做到这一点。我的梦想是我真的很想要一顶那种上面有大朵鲜花、蜂鸟会在上面觅食的帽子。所以，珍娜想朝着托尼奖努力。而我想朝着让蜂鸟在我的帽子上觅食努力。
Where do you land? Those are very disparate dreams. Well, I don't even know how to top that. Honestly, boy, I'm so content with certainly my professional life. I've been so lucky. I can't maybe do a play at some point. Would you ever do theater? Yeah, yeah.
你觉得你属于哪一种？这些梦想的跨度可真大。好吧，我都不知道该怎么接话了。老实说，天哪，我对自己的职业生涯真的很满足。我太幸运了。也许以后某个时候我可以去演个舞台剧。你以后还会演舞台剧吗？会，会的。
And I've been talking to a couple of theaters about maybe doing something. Yeah, maybe somewhere down the road. I haven't done a play. Well, since Nancy and I got married, it's been 27 years since I've done a play. So. But you are a classically trained actor. Oh, yes. Yes.
我一直在和几家剧院商量演点什么的事。对，也许以后某个时机会吧。我还没演过舞台剧。好吧，自从南希和我结婚以来，我已经27年没演过舞台剧了。所以。但你可是受过古典训练的演员。哦，是的。是的。
You were of all of us. We always talk about how like there were a bunch of the people who were the theater nerds. And then there were the like comedy, sketch comedy improv nerds on our set. But you were both. You studied theater and also studied improv. I was just a nerd. You double nerded it is what I'm getting at. You you did both.
在我们的剧组里，你是。我们总是谈论剧组里有一群人是戏剧书呆子。然后还有喜剧、小品喜剧、即兴喜剧书呆子。但你两者兼具。你既学过戏剧，也学过即兴表演。我只是个书呆子。我的意思是你是双料书呆子。你两样都沾。
Yeah. I mean, it was. Yeah, I would like to do. I'm with you. I'd like to do some. Maybe we should do something together. Let's do it. Oh, let's do some Broadway.
对。我是说，确实如此。对，我想做点。我也一样。我想做点。也许我们应该一起合作点什么。我们干吧。哦，我们去百老汇演点什么吧。
I would come and watch it with your hat. And finally, Steve, you just worked with Mr. John Krasinski on his movie. If, how was it, to team up with him again? Really fun. Was that great? Well, I'm supposed to contractually, I'm supposed to say. That's right. Yeah.
我会戴着你的那顶帽子去捧场的。最后，史蒂夫，你刚刚和约翰·卡拉辛斯基先生合作了他的电影。再次与他合作感觉怎么样？真的非常有趣。很棒吗？好吧，在合同上我理应这么说。没说错。对。
Yeah. Do you need to get out the piece of paper? Do you want to read directly from it? John Krasinski. is the most wonderful. It was great. And he was such a good director. I mean, obviously, since the office, boy, has he, like, really shown himself as a fine director.
对。你需要把那张纸拿出来吗？你想直接照着念吗？约翰·卡拉辛斯基。是最棒的。合作感觉太棒了。而且他是一个非常优秀的导演。我是说，很显然，自从《办公室》之后，天哪，他真的展现出自己是一位优秀的导演。
But did you know Yanuz Kaminsky is his DP on this movie? No. Who is Steven Spielberg's DP? Like, he is the best director of photography in the business. He's a legend. And so, you know. Wow. That's, it's a huge deal.
但你知道亚努斯·卡明斯基是这部电影的摄影指导吗？不知道。那是谁？史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的御用摄影指导？他是业内最顶级的摄影指导。他是个传奇。所以，你知道的。哇。这，这绝对是件大事。
And I think such a sign of respect to John that this person wants to, you know, wanted to work together with him. So that's, I, yeah, he's, he's, he's an amazing, he's a amazingly talented guy. And so, yeah, just great to see him. Like you guys. It's like, wow. Yeah. It's exactly like the last time we saw each other. There's like no time has passed.
而且我认为这充分体现了对约翰的尊重，因为这样的大咖愿意，你知道的，愿意和他合作。所以，我，是的，他，他，他是一个了不起的人，一个才华横溢的人。所以，是的，能见到他真的很棒。就像你们一样。感觉就像，哇。对。这感觉和我们上次见面一模一样。就好像时间从未流逝过一样。
We definitely felt that too. Like when he zoomed in, we were just cracking up. We had to like stop laughing so we could do like our interview with him because we just got so tickled. I love that. This is, you know, BJ was on and he said to us, he was like, you guys, office family forever. And that's absolutely how I feel. Like family. Thanks for coming, Steve.
我们当时确实也有这种感觉。就像他加入视频连线时，我们俩直接笑喷了。我们不得不先克制住笑声，然后才能开始对他的采访，因为我们实在太开心了。我太喜欢这样了。你知道的，B.J.来做节目时，他对我们说，你们知道的，办公室大家庭永远都在。这绝对是我内心的真实感受。就像一家人一样。谢谢你来做客，史蒂夫。
Yeah. Whatever. Oh, sorry. You got to get back to your leaf mulching. Jeez. Got a busy day there. man, you don't know the half of it. Well, truly, thank you.
对。随便吧。哦，抱歉。你得回去碎树叶了。天哪。今天有一堆忙不完的事呢。老兄，你根本不知道这有多忙。不过，真心谢谢你们。
Yes. Thank you. So good to see you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
是的。谢谢你们。很高兴见到你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience出品的一档播客，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audience的执行制作人是利亚·里丝·丹尼斯。本期播客由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是里士满树，由克里德·布拉顿创作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。